Lul
Henrik2017, moin
Der Bada ist auch da
Mein Kollege auf der Arbeit heißt Henrik
Ich glaub nicht, dass ihr was miteinander zu tun habt
Aber er fällt mir nur gerade irgendwie ein
Windows hat mich eben wieder übelst abgefuckt, Leute
Ja
Ne, so neu ist das nicht
So neu ist das nicht
Ähm, Twitch Prime, ja
Twitch Prime gibt's noch
Twitch Prime, gibt's sowas von
Gestern erst jemand subscribed
Auf Twitch mit Prime
Ich weiß, dass das funktioniert
Windows-Settings haben mich eben übelst abgefuckt
Ähm, da hab ich mir gedacht
Wir probieren einfach nochmal
Ne neue Linux-Distribution
Aus im Livestream
Livestream
Tains auf Stufe 1, 6 Monate
Eier, ja
Aber richtig Hardcore-Eier, ja
Und zwar, soweit ich gelesen hab
Oh
Das ist wieder so ne Musik
So ein Musik-Stream, der sich nicht entscheiden kann
Ob er laut oder leise
Sein möchte
Was ist am Ende mit Pop!OS rausgekommen?
Ähm, wenn man ein vorkonfiguriertes Ubuntu
Haben will, war glaube ich ein Ubuntu, ne
War das ganz okay
Das, was die versprochen haben auf ihrer Website
War etwas sehr, ähm
Sehr vollmundige Versprechungen, ja
Bisschen übertrieben
So, und, ähm
So wie es aussieht, müssen wir heute
Zwei Sachen ausprobieren, nämlich
Oder zumindest mal angucken
Und zwar gibt's das ganze
Achso, man kann sich eine Ultimate Edition kaufen für 39€
Da, äh, verzichte ich mal drauf
Sondern wir müssen die Light Edition und die, äh, äh
Core Edition downloaden
Weil das eine hat
Einen Minimaldesktop, der sich wohl auch für VMs ganz gut eignet
Und das andere ist wahrscheinlich ein stinknormales Gnome 3
Gucken wir mal
Zumindest, die bewerben mir das ganze auch relativ, ähm, großartig
Toll das ist, auf ihrer Homepage
Bin da ein bisschen skeptisch
Ich meine
Die schreiben hier zum Beispiel solche Sachen wie
Okay, solid ist es
Das Ding basiert auf Ubuntu
Ubuntu ist relativ stabil
Ähm, dass es resistent gegenüber Viren ist
Es ist halt ein Linux auf dem Desktop
Das ist per Default, ähm
Kein großartiges Ziel von Viren, ja
Ähm
Runs fast on all computers and new
Das probieren wir mal aus
Also wer noch so einen Computer am Start hat
Das ist ein bisschen
Ich weiß nicht, ob der sich da noch einen Linux drauf installiert
Ähm
Hier, das hier meine ich
Das ist ein bisschen sehr, ähm
Weit ausgeholt, ja
Und zwar, sie schreiben hier
Äh
Vollständig Microsoft Office kompatibel
Professional Photo Editing
Also mir, ganz ehrlich
Mir fällt unter Linux
Nichts ein
Was full Microsoft Office kompatibel ist
Man darf nämlich nicht vergessen
Nicht mal Microsoft Office selber
Ist Microsoft Office kompatibel
Deswegen habe ich so meine Zweifel
Das ist meine, es wird LibreOffice sein im Endeffekt
Was sonst?
Die haben alle LibreOffice drauf, ja
Ähm
Open Office
Die, äh, die Chinesen haben, äh, wie, wie
WPSP, WPS
Kingsoft Office haben die immer drauf
Ähm
Aber nachdem ja
Noch nicht mal Office selbst mit Office
Kompatibel ist, habe ich so meine Frage
Oder aber
Guldilo, der könnte recht haben
Vielleicht ist es, äh, sagen sie einfach
Du kannst Office 365 verwenden
Aber das glaube ich ehrlich gesagt nicht
Ähm
Moin, Premader
Ähm, was ich auch ein bisschen sehr
Ähm, geschönt finde
Ist diese Aussage hier
Da habe ich auch ganz große Zweifel, ob das stimmt
Ähm, Professional Photo Editing
Software, also
Da drauf wird garantiert kein neues
Photoshop laufen, garantiert
Nicht
Das kann ich euch sagen, so sicher
Wie das Abend in der Kirche, dass da drauf
Kein Photoshop laufen wird
Ähm, ich bin mir nämlich noch nicht
Mal sicher, ob es überhaupt irgendwie
Mittlerweile nen, wie auch immer
Geart, nen Hack gibt, um dieses
Adobe Cloud Zeug unter Linux
Laufen zu lassen, wir können, wir können ja
Mal gucken gerade, aber es ist auf jeden Fall
Nicht so ohne weiteres möglich
Äh, also anscheinendlich
Play on Linux
Story Creative Cloud
He, Script Calling does not work
Und dann mit Wine
Wahrscheinlich läuft's
Irgendwie
Mehr schlecht als recht
Und viele Sachen in Photoshop würden wahrscheinlich nicht funktionieren
Zum Beispiel hat Photoshop
Ja schon seit einer geraumen Zeit
Oder die meisten
Äh, Grafikprogramme haben ja mittlerweile schon ein bisschen
GPU Acceleration
Was äh
In Wine
Unter emulierten Verhältnissen
Wahrscheinlich nicht funktionieren wird
Kann es sein, dass der Stream Aussätze hat wegen meinem
Download? Du hast das schon mal gesehen
Okay, ja dann werben sie
Noch mit, äh hier, unzähligen
Apps, ähm Games
Vorinstalliert, mal gucken, und Steam
Wobei Steam halt auch unter
Unter nem Ubuntu nicht
Sonderlich, ähm
Schwierig zu installieren ist, ja
Gut, damit
Werben alle, inwieweit es
Stimmt, wissen wir nicht
Die Chancen stehen ganz gut, weil's im Endeffekt
Ein Ubuntu Reskin ist
So, ähm, kompatibel mit
Ähm
Documents, Musik, Foto
Was auch immer
You can even run many Windows Apps using Wine
Okay, Wine ist anscheinend auch schon standardmäßig dabei
Da probieren wir mal was aus
Ähm, es ist besonders
Einfach zugänglich für alle Leute
Es ist super flexibel
Ähm, man kann es neben Windows
Und MacOS installieren, ja gut
Das kann man mit jedem Linux machen
Ja, das ist jetzt nix
So, und deswegen auch das Steamtitel
Es macht meine Computer
Besser
Welche Linux Distribution würdest du nem Windows Umsteiger
Empfehlen, es ist die Frage
Inwieweit er sich mit seinem Computer beschäftigen
Will, wenn er wirklich einfach nur
Basics der Sachen verwenden möchte
Äh, und es
Irgendwie noch halbwegs ähnlich
Äh, zu nem Windows bedienbar soll
Da soll er einfach Linux Mint nehmen
Ähm, Ubuntu
Kann er auch nehmen, im Prinzip kommt er aufs gleiche raus
Ähm
Ich würde sagen, nehm Linux Mint
Wenn du dich ein bisschen
Mit Linux beschäftigen möchtest, dann bin ich
Ja für Manjaro
Mario Kart
Di di di di di di di
Hi Max
Fragt
Der Colvin Vortex fragt
Macht es Sinn
Meine Festplatte zu verschlüsseln, wenn ich kein TPM Modul habe
Ja unbedingt macht das Sinn
Du brauchst kein TPM Modul um deine Festplatte zu verschlüsseln
Wozu?
Ich habe meine Festplatte schon
Ich wollte jetzt gerade sagen, Jahrzehnte
Verschlüsselt, aber
Das reicht noch nicht mal
Jahrzehnte, die Mehrzahl ist schwierig, aber
Ich habe meine Festplatte schon ewig
Über 10 Jahre verschlüsselt
12, 13, 14 Jahre
TrueCrypt, VeraCrypt
Ähm
Ein riesen Vorteil hat das, wenn man seine Festplatte
Verschlüsselt
Ähm, man kann seine Festplatte
Bedenkenlos wegwerfen
Das ist für mich auch der riesen Vorteil
An einem vollverschlüsselten System
Ich kann eine SSD nehmen aus meinem Rechner
Ich kann den Rucksack nehmen, stecken
Irgendwo mit hinnehmen
Ich kann die einfach auf den Müll schmeißen
Und es kann kein Mensch jemals mit dem Inhalt was anfangen
Also zumindest nicht so lange das Universum
Existiert oder jemand Quantencomputer
Salonfähig macht
Was hältst du von Apple T2 Security Chip
Ich habe keine Ahnung was der macht
Gibt es ein Command
Für den Chat
Und man kann seinen Kodalpunkten zu flexen
Äh
Also wenn Nightbot was eingebaut hat
Dann ja, wenn nicht dann nicht
Wie verschlüsselt man seine Festplatte
Mit Windows
Die Frage die du dir erstmal stellen musst ist
Wenn du deine Festplatte mit Windows verschlüsseln willst
Willst du sie mit Bordmitteln verschlüsseln
Oder willst du sie mit Open Source Tools verschlüsseln
Oder ist es dir scheiß egal
Bordmittel haben natürlich den Vorteil
Du musst nichts zusätzlich installieren
Und sind besser integriert
Wobei man halt sagen muss
Das ist eigentlich schwierig zu installieren
Und ist auch ziemlich easy
Ich habe einen
Äh nicht Ubikey
Ubikey habe ich
Für Verschlüsselungskram
Verwende ich aber nicht
Habe ich mir irgendwann mal gekauft
Aber
Verwende ich irgendwie nicht
Wobei das eigentlich eine coole Sache ist
Ja und es gibt auch
Eine ziemlich gute Alternative
Nicht Googles Alternative
Wie hieß das denn das andere?
Ubikeys?
Ne ich weiß nicht
Aber die Dinger sind eigentlich ganz cool
So als 2 Faktor Authentifizierung
Es ist halt nicht mehr komplett Open Source
Die ganze Ubikey Geschichte
Deswegen hatte ich mich auch mal nach Alternativen umgeguckt
Ubico
War das das?
War so immer
Egal
Also um nochmal zurück zu kommen
Warning
Machen wir machen wir
Was haben wir eigentlich?
Genug
Wir können auch die Pop OS Installation wegschmeißen
Falls ich die noch habe
So aber vorher muss ich noch auf ein paar weitere Fragen
Im Chat eingehen
Ein paar Sachen
Ne habe ich schon alles weggeschmissen
Und zwar die erste Frage die noch offen ist
Wie man seine Festplatten verschlüsselt unter Windows
Entweder mit BitLocker
Das ist standardmäßig dabei
Habe ich aber noch nie gemacht
Ich verwende immer das da
Das ist die einzige Software aus Frankreich die ich verwende
Ich verwende immer das hier
Das ist total simpel
Du downloadest das einfach
Übrigens
Du kannst natürlich auch das schöne an Veracrypt ist
Du kannst das ganze auch unter Mac und Linux
Öffnen wenn du willst
Ja und richtig
BitLocker gibt es nicht in der Windows Home Version
Das stimmt
Kann man damit auch die Systemplatte verschalten?
Ja klar
Du installierst dir das
Und dann ich kann es dir jetzt
Ich habe leider keine
Habe ich noch eine Windows VM
Da könnte ich dir zeigen wie das ganze ausschaut
Haben wir noch die Windows VM
Ne haben wir nicht
Sonst hätte ich dir gezeigt
Es ist eigentlich ziemlich easy wie das funktioniert
Ich würde vorher immer ein Backup machen
Ich würde nicht einfach hier quasi on the fly
Verschlüsseln
Mir ist noch nie was passiert
Aber ich meine letztendlich
Ist das ja
Das was so ein Verschlüsselungs-Trojaner auch macht
Nur das du standardmäßig den Key für hast
Die Daten auf deiner Platte sind so nicht mehr lesbar
Das heißt wenn irgendwas schief geht
Ist es auf jeden Fall nicht verkehrt ein Backup zu haben
Du musst kein Vollbackup machen
Einfach die wichtigsten Sachen das man im Zweifelsfall neu installieren kann
Ich hatte noch nie Probleme
Aber man weiß ja nie
Ne aber das ist ziemlich einfach mit Veracrypt das ganze zu machen
Ich glaube die haben ja sogar
Hier Beginners Tutorial da steht es doch sogar
Du hast zwei Varianten
Hast du das mit Veracrypt und dem BSI mitbekommen?
Ne was ist da?
Das habe ich nicht mitbekommen
BSI musste Audit Ergebnisse zu Truecrypt veröffentlichen
Okay
Was war da?
Unveröffentlicht gelassen
Ah die haben es unveröffentlicht gelassen
So nach dem Motto das man das theoretisch ausnutzen kann
Wenn man möchte
Stimmt man weiß ja bis heute nicht warum Truecrypt dicht gemacht hat
Ne
Oder beziehungsweise Truecrypt nicht mehr gibt
Laut hat
Sicherheitskenntnisse übertrugt
Es sei denn
Ne gut das ist ja von einem Backdoor jetzt noch relativ weit weg
Sicherheitserkenntnisse über Truecrypt blablabla
Also von einem Backdoor steht jetzt da nichts
Ich meine natürlich ist es auch schlecht
Wenn man die Verschlüsselung einfacher als durch Brute Force entschlüsseln kann
Aber ein Backdoor ist vielleicht ein bisschen übertrieben jetzt genannt
So zu nennen
Ne habe ich nicht mitgekriegt
Aber wundert mich ehrlich gesagt auch nicht
Ich denke aber man ist
Auf jeden Fall
Auf einem guten Weg
Wenn man seine Platte mit
Veracrypt verschlüsselt hat
Im Vergleich zu einfach nur plaintext
Wie gesagt es mag vielleicht nicht dagegen schützen
Wenn es jetzt irgendwie der Geheimdienst auf jemand abgesehen hat
Aber ich behaupte mal
Der Geheimdienst hat es auf die wenigsten von uns abgesehen
Sondern es geht einfach um
Komfortgeschichten
Wie gesagt ich finde es super das ich meine Festplatte mitnehmen kann
Ich finde es super das ich meine Festplatte einfach in den Müll schmeißen kann
Ja
Ich bin einfach beruhigt weil ich weiß
Hey selbst wenn mal einer sagen wir mal
Laptop Cloud
Das man mit dem Inhalt zumindest nichts anfangen kann
Ich meine auf dem Laptop sind ja auch so Sachen drauf
Wie vielleicht irgendwelche
Irgendein Passwort Save
Den muss man zwar auch erstmal zusätzlich entschlüsseln
Aber ich meine allein schon wenn man dran kommt
Ist schon mal doof
Irgendwelche Logins die sind im Browser gespeichert
Sind das Wlan Passwort oder solche Geschichten
Und da ist es natürlich super wenn man die Platte einfach voll verschlüsselt hat
Da kann man
Kann man eigentlich auch nicht viel falsch machen
Und
Ist mittlerweile auch ziemlich gut
Von einem voll verschlüsselten System
Ähm da
Die CPUs mittlerweile
Wenn man AES verwendet
Das in Hardware
Quasi Latency Free
Bandbreiten
Ohne Einschränkungen
Großartig verwenden kann
Also da muss man
Da muss man sich echt keine Gedanken machen
Dass das System irgendwie langsam wird
Ähm genau
Boss Baba
So geht das ganze
Du hast die Auswahl zwischen
Eine Verschlüsselung von
Einem einzelnen
Also du hast drei Sachen zur Auswahl
Du kannst ein Laufwerk verschlüsseln
Du kannst eine Datei erstellen
Die du dann als Laufwerk in Windows benutzen kannst
Also quasi
Du verwendest ein Laufwerk in Windows
Da kannst du alle deine Dateien reinlegen
Und unter der Haube verschlüsselt ist das halt eine Datei
Die irgendwo auf deinem Rechner liegt
Oder du kannst eine Vollverschlüsselung von deinem System machen
Du kannst einen Container erstellen
Das ist quasi eine verschlüsselte Datei
Die du dann in Windows Explorer als Laufwerk verwendest
Du kannst ein Laufwerk verschlüsseln
Und du kannst dein komplettes System
Verschlüsseln
Muss allerdings klar sein
Wenn du dein komplettes System verschlüsselst
Dann musst du bei jedem Booten
Musst du ein Passwort eingeben
Um deine Festplatte zu entschlüsseln
Und was ja auch klar sein muss
Im Gegensatz zu BitLocker
Wo es ja irgendwelche Hintertürchen
Ja gibt
Ob noch gibt
Aber auch definitiv gab
Das Microsoft Passwort dafür herstellen kann
Wenn du hier dein Passwort verlierst
Das ist eine Arschkarte
Dann ist vorbei
Passwort weg Daten weg
Du hast keine Chance das irgendwie zu Recover
Es gibt eine Recover CD
Die ist aber nicht dafür gedacht
Laufwerke zu entschlüsseln
Das ist auch so ein bisschen was
Was viele Leute glaube ich am Anfang falsch verstehen
Wenn sie Recover CD oder Recover USB Stick lesen
Der Recover USB Stick
Beziehungsweise die Recover CD
Ist nicht dafür da
Festplatten zu entschlüsseln
Oder Laufwerke zu entschlüsseln
Wenn man das Passwort vergessen hat
Das wäre ja bescheuert
Nein die ist dafür da
Wenn die Festplatte beschädigt ist
Das ist ein großer Unterschied
Oder manche Sachen nicht mehr lesen kann
Dann kann ich mit dem Passwort wohlgemerkt
Und der Recover CD
Mit Glück
So
Und dann hast du noch eine weitere Variante
Die habe ich aber ehrlich gesagt noch nie verwendet
Du kannst deine Laufwerke auch verstecken
Das heißt
Du kannst quasi
Einen Windows drauf installieren
Und in diesem Windows nochmal
Einen Windows quasi verstecken
So quasi
Yo Dog mäßig
Du kannst quasi
Einen Windows installieren
Und wenn dann
Du gleich wieder
Einen Windows installierst
Dann hast du
Einer Windows auch
Einer Windows ist
Und wenn dann
Du vielleicht
Einen Windows installierst
Dann ist
Einer Windows
gar nicht
Das heißt
halt ein Standard Windows und
es sieht so aus, als wäre es dein normaler Rechner,
aber in Wirklichkeit ist dein richtiges
Windows, quasi deine richtigen Daten sind in einem
Hidden Volume.
Ob das jemand wirklich verwendet, weiß ich nicht.
Ich habe es noch nie verwendet.
Ich verwende das ganz
normale Standard
System
Entire System Drive Encryption.
Das heißt, wenn ich reboote, muss ich
beim Booten ein Passwort eingeben.
Genau, kannst du jetzt mal angucken.
Es sieht komplizierter aus, als es ist.
Du kannst dir auch ein paar Guides auf YouTube angucken.
Es ist ziemlich, ziemlich einfach
und der Guide sehe ich auch gerade nicht für
Vollverschlüsselung, sondern für
Laufwerke.
Nicht für Laufwerke, für Dateien.
Also für Dateien
mounten als Laufwerke. Guck dir mal ein Guide an.
Es ist ziemlich einfach.
Ich behaupte mal, kann im Prinzip
eigentlich jeder.
Hat der VeraCrypt
einen Vorteil gegenüber BitLocker? Ja gut.
Wie man das sieht,
also wenn es für dich einen Vorteil ist,
dass das Programm quasi
offen ist, dass es schon mal
zumindest für TrueCrypt einen Audit
gab, wobei man jetzt ja gesehen hat, dass das jetzt
auch nicht so viel heißen muss,
dass es relativ weit verbreitet ist und
dass Microsoft kein
Passwort Recovery Option
hat,
dann ja. Also du kannst dir relativ
sicher sein,
dass wenn du deine Platte mit
VeraCrypt verschlüsselst,
dass die keiner
bis zum Untergang des Universums
jemals entschlüsselt, wenn du eine ordentliche Festplatte hast.
Außer wir machen Riesenfortschritte,
was kryptografische Sachen angeht.
Und nicht einfach nur Riesenfortschritte,
sondern
Lichtjahre,
lange, weite
Fortschritte,
wenn du ein ordentliches Passwort hast.
Was hast du benutzt um deine Festplatte zu verschlüsseln?
Ich benutze seit über 10 Jahren
TrueCrypt bzw. VeraCrypt.
So, ich muss gerade im Chat runterscrollen.
Da braucht der Trojaner nur noch ein Passwort zu ändern.
Also einfach ist es nicht ein Passwort zu ändern.
Aber
ein Trojaner, der Zugriff der
Adminrechte quasi hat auf deinem PC,
der kann ja alles lesen.
Weil wenn du Windows gestartet hast, nachdem du
das Passwort eingegeben hast,
also sprich zur Laufzeit ist die Sache ja entschlüsselt.
Also würde Windows ja nicht funktionieren.
Also sprich, du musst den Rechner
schon ausschalten, dass das dann auch sicher ist
danach. Das heißt, wenn
jetzt hier jemand durchs Fenster
springt und mir die Pistole vor die
Nase hält und sagt, Max, weg vom Rechner
und das Ganze ist entsperrt,
dann kann er da Vollzugriff drauf.
Gut, ich meine, ich weiß nicht,
was er damit will, aber
er hätte Vollzugriff drauf.
Benutzt du
VeraCrypt für Windows und Linux?
Ne, ich verwende VeraCrypt nur für
Windows.
Und
für Linux verwende ich ganz normal
Lux, was eingebaut ist.
Der Quai fragt, Max, hast du vor einer Weile
was? Du hattest doch vor einer Zeitung,
einen neuen Server mit der festverleuteten
CPU gebaut.
Gibt es irgendwo eine Teileliste?
Äh, ich, ja.
Ja, aber ich weiß nicht mehr wo.
Wir haben, wir hatten, wir haben mal eine Teileliste
gemacht. Sieht man bei Geizhals
seine, seine
gespeicherten
Listen?
Da? Nass.
Ist es das?
Ja, das ist, wobei,
ne,
das war mal so eine Idee,
was man bauen könnte,
aber das ist es nicht.
Ja, aber wenn du, wenn du konkrete Hartz-Versachen
wissen willst, jetzt kann ich dir das auch schnell
sagen. Wie ist das bei Windows 10
Upgrade? Du musst es ja wieder
entschlüsseln, oder? Das kommt
auf das Windows Update an. Das letzte
Windows Update war kein Problem.
Der hat keine Neuinstallation gemacht.
Und lustigerweise, das Windows Update
davor ging auch.
Das heißt, ich habe die Vermutung,
dass Windows Update
wohl mittlerweile
funktioniert.
Müssten wir sich mal schlau machen.
Ob das einfach nur Glück war,
dass es funktioniert hat, ohne Entschlüssel
das letzte Mal? Weil das letzte Mal war ganz
merkwürdig, beim letzten größeren
Update.
Ja, Chat, genau.
Ähm, das letzte Mal war
ganz merkwürdig beim letzten großen Update.
Also nicht das jetzt aktuelle, das war ja keine
Windows Update-Neuinstallation,
sondern das davor.
Ich habe es wie immer versucht,
zu entschlüsseln
und Windows Update zu machen.
Das hat ums Verrecken nicht funktioniert.
Dann habe ich es dann einfach wieder verschlüsselt und habe mir gesagt,
Windows leckt mich und dann hat das Updaten funktioniert.
Ähm,
Namen des Boards.
Das Board habe ich
für die 10 Gigabit-Karte
hier unten drin.
Es sei denn, wenn du auch 10 Gigabit bauen willst.
Und als Gehäuse, aber wie gesagt,
ich würde es eh nicht wirklich empfehlen.
Das ist sehr experimentell, was ich da gebaut habe.
Also als Gehäuse habe ich
das günstigste
das günstigste Rack,
Mountable-Gehäuse
genommen mit Wechselrahmen drin.
Also auch jetzt nicht
das da habe ich als Gehäuse.
Also das ist nicht das Qualitätswunder.
Aber man muss halt sagen,
das ist das günstigste 10G-Nass,
was man sich irgendwie zusammenschustern kann,
was ich da gebaut habe.
Ähm, welches Filesystem auf Linux?
Meistens
X4 oder XFS.
Allerdings aktuell habe ich auf meiner
fetten 4HE-Kiste.
Also das mit den 3x10TB.
Mein aktuelles, äh, mein aktueller Server,
den ich hier stehen habe,
den ich gerade am ablösen bin.
Da habe ich ZFS drauf.
Kannst du mal was zu Browsern sagen,
warum du zum Beispiel Chromium benutzt?
Tja, gute Frage.
Nächste Frage.
Ich habe, glaube ich, mal angefangen mit Chromium,
weil ich nicht wollte,
dass ich aus Versehen,
ja, jetzt lacht mich aus, ja,
aber,
ich wollte nicht aus Versehen, ähm,
Videostreamen über Chromecast
auf den Fernsehtrüben.
Das ist...
Jetzt, der Chat, Chat, also, also wirklich,
Chat, was ihr wieder denkt,
was das für Videos sind, das kann ich,
das ist wieder hier, Chat, schlimm,
schlimm. Nein, natürlich,
natürlich, nein, nein, nein, nein, nur,
nur, äh,
das ist genauso, wie ich bei Torrent nur
Linux-Distribution runterlade.
Naja, zumindest, ähm, angefangen habe ich,
dass ich nicht aus Versehen, nein, es ging
überhaupt nicht um irgendwelche Porn-Filmchen
oder sonst was, die ursprüngliche Sache war
wirklich, dass ich nicht aus Versehen Filme
auf den Fernsehtrüben streamen wollte,
unabhängig davon, welche Filme, weil
im Chrome ist es halt so,
wenn du irgendwas aufmachst,
sei es irgendwie YouTube, sonst was,
ähm,
wobei,
ist gar nicht, doch, genau,
das kann halt durchaus passieren, dass du
anstatt Kinomodus, äh,
mal hier aus Versehen ein bisschen
falsch klickst und schon castest du irgendwelche
Sachen auf dein, auf dein Fernseher,
was halt, ehrlich gesagt, ziemlich doof ist.
Ich habe danach gecheckt,
dass man das in Chrome auch deaktivieren kann,
aber das ging dann nach einem Update
nicht, und da habe ich mir gedacht, okay, wenn ich jedesmal
bei jedem Chrome-Update jetzt neu gucken muss,
wie ich Chromecast ausschalte, dann
mache ich es einfach so,
weil manchmal möchte ich ja Chromecast haben,
da installiere ich mir einfach Chrome mit Chromecast
und Chromium ohne Chromecast.
Kodex und alles,
und gut ist.
Was ist denn an dem NAS zu experimentell?
Naja, zum Beispiel, dass die 10-Gigabit-Karte,
also erstens, dass der PCI-Express
Slot zu langsam ist für 10G,
dass eine System-SSD
und eine, äh,
Magnetplatte eigentlich
jetzt nicht so der Performance-Burner
sind für 10G, ich meine, es ist schneller,
es ist, sie bringen
mehr, als über 1 Gigabit rübergehen würde,
aber von 10 Gigabit sind sie weit entfernt,
und auch die,
das kannst du ja mal zeigen,
und auch diese Geschichte hier mit,
ich habe doch irgendwo mal ein Bild
von meinem Server gehabt, vom aktuellen,
ich glaube, das habe ich nicht gespeichert,
kann das sein?
Ah, hier!
Da, genau, da ist er.
Äh, und auch das, quasi
vom PCI-Express-Slot,
wobei, Linus Tech Tips macht es ja auch so,
haben wir ja letztens gesehen,
ähm, dass, ähm, quasi vom
PCI-Express-Slot
zur 10 Gigabit-Netzwerkkarte hier
dieses, dieses Erweiterungskabel
rübergebt, äh,
könnte auch schöner sein,
ja? Hehehe, Antti,
genau, nur Linux,
natürlich über Torrent nur
Linux-ISOs.
Warum nicht Firefox? Auf Firefox habe ich auch
installiert. Ich habe Chrome,
Chromium,
Firefox und
Vivaldi. Vier Browser,
vier Browser Master Rays, beste.
Ähm, okay, ich sehe schon, wir kommen
hier nicht zur Linux-Installation gerade, aber
muss ja auch mal Zeit sein für eine
Runde
Fragen beantworten im Chat.
Ähm, habe ich
jetzt, habe ich jetzt hier übersehen?
Ah, also, na.
Mittlerweile habe ich euch das Bild
ja gezeigt, mittlerweile ist das Ganze zu
und, ähm, gut,
da stand er noch hier in der Ecke
auf dem Haufen Müll.
Hehehe, äh,
mittlerweile ist er zu und steht hier rum und ist auch
schön beschriftet. Aber
so die High-End-Hardware ist es natürlich
nicht. Dafür ist es halt gnadenlos
günstig für 250 Euro
einen 10G NAS zusammenzuschustern.
Ist halt auch
anspruchsvoll, ja.
So, ähm, also was habe ich
übersehen auf dem, im Chat?
Welche
Unify Access Points hast
du? Bei dir bist du zufrieden mit der
Reichweite? Ja, das ist richtig nice.
Also ich habe,
ich meine, ich bin am überlegen, ob
ich auch einen dritten dazu stelle. Ich habe einen
ähm,
ich habe den da. Das war der erste,
den ich gekauft habe.
Den da. Der ist aber nicht mehr aktuell,
ja. Der kostet, ähm, da
hier so. Also den da habe ich.
Das war der erste, den ich mir gekauft habe.
Das coole an dem ist,
und das ist tatsächlich
echt enorm praktisch, leider
hat Ubiquiti das
abgeschafft. Und zwar,
der hat unten
einen USB-Anschluss.
Und das ist nämlich ganz nützlich, weil du betreibst das
Ding ja über PoE. Das heißt, es kriegt Strom
über, über das Netzwerkkabel.
Und hier
hinten hast du einen USB-Port. Den USB-Port
haben die mal eingeführt für
irgendwelche erweiterbaren Alarmsysteme
und sonst was, aber haben es nie verwendet. Das heißt,
die neueren Access Points, die
haben das nicht mehr. Und
das coole an dem Port war,
ich habe da drüber
meinen Raspberry Pi angeschlossen,
auf dem die Unify Software
lief. Das war schon ganz
praktisch, dass du keinen extra Stecker gebraucht hast.
Allerdings ist der USB-Port
von so unglaublich schlechter
Qualität gewesen.
Sonst habe ich das noch nie erlebt.
Das war das erste Mal, dass ich das erlebt habe,
dass der USB-Port einen Wackelkontakt hatte
nach zwei Wochen.
Weil auf einmal hast du den Tisch, wo du das draufgelegt
hast, ein bisschen gewackelt
und zack hat sich der Raspberry ausgeschaltet.
Und ich dachte erst,
das Problem ist, dass das Billig-China-Kabel
das ist nämlich so ein USB
Stromkabel gewesen,
da wo ich mir mal die 50er
Box aus China bestellt habe,
die ganz billigen, die unter einem Euro das Kabel-Box,
war da dran und
da dachte ich erst,
das ist ein scheiß China-USB-Kabel, was kaputt ist.
Aber nein, der USB-Port
hatte einen Wackelkontakt.
Mir war bis dahin gar nicht klar, dass
USB-Ports wirklich Wackelkontakt haben können.
Also im Port drinnen.
So.
Was ist das? Das ist ein Access Point.
So. Und also den habe ich
einmal, das war der erste, den ich gekauft habe.
Und jetzt habe ich noch ein
Nano-HD.
Der sieht fast genauso aus,
der ist ein Ticken kleiner, nicht viel,
ein bisschen kleiner.
Dafür ist
der 5 GHz Bereich besser.
Kostet allerdings auch ein Ticken
mehr.
Also wenn es wirklich rein um die
Kohle geht, dann würde ich den
nehmen, aber ansonsten, wenn ich mir
jetzt neu kaufen würde, würde ich zweimal
den dann nehmen. Ich bin nämlich auch gerade am überlegen,
ob ich mir nicht noch einen dritten hole.
Also ich nehme den
quasi noch in die andere Ecke vom Haus
nochmal so ein.
Das einzige Problem, warum ich das nicht mache,
ist, ich habe in dieser anderen Ecke im Haus
nicht so ohne weiteres
ein Netzwerkkabel.
Da müsste ich erst mir was einfallen lassen.
Aber das wäre halt auch die Ecke, wo es dann raus
zur Terrasse geht, wo es halt cool wäre,
wenn da irgendwo an der Wand direkt
ein Access Point stehen würde.
So, das sind die Access Points, die ich habe.
Welchen Verschlüsselungsalgorithmus
soll ich bei Veracrypt wählen?
AES, immer AES.
Und Hardware
Beschleunigung aktivieren.
Flüssigmetallschleim sagt, ich nutze eigentlich
nur Firefox. Firefox ist nach wie vor
auch mein Lieblingsbrowser.
Ich benutze zwar mittlerweile hauptsächlich
oder öfter Chrome als Firefox,
aber Firefox ist trotzdem mein Lieblingsbrowser.
Klingt jetzt irgendwie ein bisschen
paradox, ja, ich weiß, aber
ist so. Knallibeer,
Vivaldi, ja, bester.
Edge Chromium, ok.
Den habe ich noch nie verwendet.
Wenn du 3x
10 TB im NAS hast, kein
RAID 0 oder wie? Wie, warum nicht?
Warum kein RAID 0? RAID 0 ist
das Beste.
Gibt es eigentlich schon ARM Server
Desktop CPUs?
Ja, man kann die ohne Probleme für Server
und Desktop jetzt schon verwenden.
Powerline? Nee, Powerline
suckt. Powerline würde ich nicht verwenden.
Also ich meine, ich extende doch
kein Access Point mit Powerline, das ist ja schon
irgendwie in sich
natürlich. Dann kann man das, kann man
machen, aber da muss schon sehr, Notlage
sehr hoch sein.
Mattsofini98, zwei
Monate, excellent.
Prime Sub.
Ups.
Falsch.
So, richtig.
MrOpie, nee,
es gibt auch eine Core Online Version, die installieren
wir jetzt, wo wir gerade dabei sind.
Ich kann das schon mal machen, während ich hier weiter
Questions beantworte.
Aber übrigens, nein, das ist ein
ZFS RAID 5,
also eine ZFS RAID 1, was
kein RAID 1 ist, sondern RAID 5, was ich
mit den 3x10 TB habe.
Kein RAID 0.
Die neuen Ryzen sollen sich
ziemlich gut für Server eignen, also
Homesurfer. Ja, wenn man die
Performance braucht, ist es keine schlechte
Idee. Also wenn man wirklich
Multicore Performance,
Multithreaded Performance braucht, zum Beispiel,
wenn man irgendwie so einen
Mediaserver mit Transcoding machen
will, dann ist so ein Ryzen sicherlich nicht verkehrt.
Hab ich? Ich muss mal kurz
gucken.
Hab ich die VMs eigentlich das letzte Mal gelöscht?
Ja. Das ist Ratchet, ja.
Du magst, du hast auch,
wahrscheinlich, wahrscheinlich bist du auch ein
Viren-Fan.
Du sammelst Viren, gib's zu.
Ähm, äh,
Linux, was ist denn das, ein Ubuntu.
Ah, passt.
Das ist im Prinzip eh wurscht.
Wir können auch Ubuntu auswählen, aber das
macht eigentlich keinen großen Unterschied.
Die Settings sind
eh die gleichen, mehr oder weniger.
Ein Kern, nein,
vier Kerne pro CPU,
ähm, 4G RAM
sollten reichen. Ich mein, die werben
bei den Betriebssystemen damit, dass es, dass
das alte Computer wieder flott macht, also
4 GB RAM sollte da dicke reichen.
NAT, jawoll,
weiter,
U-Disk, 20G reichen zum
Testen auch, Single-File,
Next, so.
Printer kommt weg,
Soundkarte lassen wir dran,
und, äh,
gut ist, Finish.
So, ich hätte auch
erst neu, was, was,
der KnalliBär schreibt,
ich hatte erst neulich festgestellt, dass
Windows 10 Pro kein Software Raid 5
machen kann.
Ich wusste gar nicht, dass Windows überhaupt Raid machen kann.
Äh,
gibt's da eine Alternative zu
außer Storage Pools? Ach stimmt, so hieß das, ja.
Keine Ahnung.
Linux installieren.
Damit ist das alles kein Problem.
Äh, so.
ISO-File. Was wollen wir
als erstes ausprobieren? Wir, wir,
wir installieren mal die Vollversion, oder?
Wir installieren mal die Vollversion
und danach installieren wir die Lite-Version.
Oh, auf geht's.
Wir haben, ja, ja, Finish, vor allem
wer nervt nicht rum. Stretch.
Ach komm, geht doch so.
Oh, Animation.
Welche CPU würdest du für ne
Workstation nehmen, wenn du mit einer Workstation
auch zocken willst? Äh, entweder
ne 3950X oder
gleich ne Threadripper
3960X. Kommt aber auch
ein bisschen
aufs Geld an, was man
ausgeben will, ne? Wahrscheinlich
rein geldmäßig ne 3950X,
wobei
ja, so ne Threadripper mit noch ein bisschen
mehr Kern auch nice ist.
Ich würd mir aber auf jeden Fall ne AMD
CPU reinbauen. Die neuen
Ryzens brauchen auch fast keinen Strom im Idle.
Auf jeden Fall deutlich weniger als früher.
Ähm, das ist so der einzige Punkt,
wo man sagen muss, da ist AMD
noch nicht so weit wie Intel.
Wenn man so im,
sagen wir mal, unteren,
aber nicht Low-End-Performance-Sektor
guckt, dafür
sehr stromsparende CPUs haben
will, da hat Intel mit den
Pentium
Silver-Dingern und, das sind
Atomnachfolger, die haben sie jetzt in Pentium Silver
umbenannt, weil Microsoft, äh,
weil Intel Five Hat Naming
benutzt, ähm, da hat
AMD nix wirklich zu bieten in der Richtung.
Das ist eigentlich auch ne super Plattform
preis-leistungsmäßig. Du kriegst ein Board,
du kriegst für 65, 70,
75 Euro nen Board mit, mit, mit
aufgelöteter, oder quasi mit CPU
dabei, die Idle
6 Watt braucht.
Ohne was, ja. Also das ist schon
nicht schlecht. Meinung zu Unraid,
ich hab's mir mal vor Jahren kurz
angeguckt, warum sie da jetzt alle
so nen Hype drum machen, ist mir nicht so ganz
verständlich. Wahrscheinlich, weil's Linus verwendet.
Weiß nicht.
Ich, ich würde, ich wüsste jetzt nicht, wozu ich's
verwenden würde. Wie sieht's mit der neuen
CPU bei dir aus? Ich hab's, wie gesagt, nicht
bestellt. Okay. Install. Wir installieren gleich.
Wir tryen nicht, wir installieren gleich.
Äh, wenn bei RAID 5 eine
Platte abraucht, kann ich die
austauschen hab, alle Daten wieder
save? In der
Theorie schon. In der Praxis
kommt's ein bisschen drauf an, wie
groß die Platten sind und wie viele Platten du in RAID
5 hast. Also in der Regel ja.
Dafür ist es da.
Weil wenn das nicht der Fall wäre,
müsste man auch kein RAID 5 verwenden.
Wo sind wir denn hier überhaupt?
Germany.
No dead keys.
Bam. Detect. Ja, das macht
Ubuntu-Abfragen. Genau. Press Y.
Yes. Press Ö.
No. Wir sind nicht französisch.
No dead keys
haben wir. Also bei RAID 5
sieht's folgendermaßen aus.
Der Sinn dahinter ist,
wenn du quasi drei Festplatten hast, eine raucht
ab, dann kannst du's quasi
aus den Informationen, die auf den anderen
zwei gespeichert sind,
wiederherstellen. Aber man muss
da ein bisschen aufpassen. Also wenn man jetzt
umso größer die Festplatten werden,
umso wahrscheinlicher ist natürlich auch mal, dass so eine Festplatte
einen Lesenfehler hat, der nicht dazu führt,
dass jetzt quasi das
komplette System verreckt, was drauf ist. Aber
was bei einem Recovery von einem RAID
schon problematisch sein könnte.
Weil bei einem RAID Recovery
verlässt sich der Controller ja drauf oder
die Software, wer auch immer das macht, dass du wirklich
es auch wiederherstellen kannst. Wenn da dann was
nicht lesbar ist, ist schlecht. Kack das mal.
Dann geht das Recovery ab.
Und
umso mehr, also umso größer die Platten
und umso mehr Platten man in den
RAID 5 packt, umso höher sind die
Chancen, dass das Recovery nicht mehr richtig
funktioniert. Das heißt, wenn man drei Platten
nimmt,
drei mal zehn Terabyte Platten oder so,
das ist okay, das kann man machen.
Wenn man da jetzt sagt, okay, ich würde,
ich nehm irgendwie, keine Ahnung, acht Platten,
da würde ich mir schon mal
Gedanken machen, ob ein RAID 5 eine gute Idee ist.
Eher nicht. Okay, Download
updates while installing. Install third party
software graphics. Jawohl, mach.
Don't participate in census.
Nein, wir machen keine Statistiken.
Continue.
Hatte AMD nicht immer mit der Wärmeentwicklung zu
kaufen? Also die aktuellen Ryzen-CPUs
lassen sich sehr gut kühlen.
Okay, das ist der ganz normale Ubuntu
Installer. Ja, erase, install,
alles gut. Geht's.
Es wäre sinnvoll, wenn du anzeigen würdest, wie groß die
Festplatte ist, die du erkannt hast. Einmal machbar.
Continue. Wir sind in Berlin.
Name, Test,
Passwort 123456.
Oh, das ist fair.
Huge. Das ist kein easy Passwort.
Das ist fair.
Next.
Okay, ist ein bisschen abgehackt.
Gucken wir mal zu. Kann ja weiter
Chatfragen beantworten, während er das installiert.
Hey, denn Ryzen ohne
Kühler.
Jede halbwegs aktuelle Desktop-
CPU ohne Kühler mag
nicht. Das ist jetzt
kein früher oder gegen
Ryzen.
Wenn du einen aktuellen Intel Desktop-
CPU nimmst, du kannst selbst
ähm, selbst in
Raspberry 4 hat Probleme
ohne Kühler.
Zwar nicht so extrem, wie es ein aktueller Desktop-
CPU von Intel oder AMD hat, aber
auch der wird ziemlich warm. Wärmer,
als sie sich so vorgestellt haben am Anfang.
Storage-Pools. Windows habe ich
noch nie verwendet. Ich weiß auch nicht.
Mir widerstrebt es auch irgendwie,
äh, ein Windows-Software-Rate zu
verwenden. Gegen MD-Rate habe ich
nichts. Also meine Lieblingsgeschichte ist
ja immer noch ZFS, wenn ich unter Linux
was Rate-mäßiges
machen muss. ZFS ist einfach
nice. Von den Features her,
die ganze Snapshot-Geschichte. Mittlerweile mit
der neuen ZFS-Version sogar
Verschlüsselung eingebaut.
Ähm,
ZFS ist eigentlich so
rundum-sorglos-Paket
an Features. Allerdings muss man
sagen, natürlich so die absolute
Top-Performance hast du da
vergleicht. Es macht halt auch viel
mehr drum herum, ja. Also wenn's dir jetzt
um die letzten
IO-Ops irgendwie geht, dann
wahrscheinlich nicht.
Und, ähm, die Handhabung
ist jetzt auch nicht so einfach. Man muss sich schon
ein paar Sachen merken. Aber ansonsten
ist ZFS, also jetzt spätestens
seit Hardware-Verschlüsselung
in ZFS drin ist, seit der letzten
Version, ist ZFS so das
universelle Ding, was man
verwenden, was man eigentlich uneingeschränkt
empfehlen kann und verwenden sollte, wenn man was braucht,
was einfach geht.
Was einfach geht, zuverlässig ist,
und, ähm,
auch unter
schlechten Bedingungen funktioniert.
Damit ich
immer ZFS nenne.
Man kann auch ZFS ohne Probleme
auf einer einzelnen Festplatte
machen. Das ist kein Ding.
Der Patrick ist auch am Start. Hoffe, du hattest schöne Weihnachten.
Ja, ordentlich gefressen.
Eating Sounds ASMR.
Was hältst du von einem Synology
Nuss? Kann man sich kaufen.
Also wenn man jetzt einfach nur was will, was
geht, wenn man einfach was hinstellen will,
wo...
hinstellen, Netzwerk anschließen,
drei Festplatten reinschieben,
dann ist ein Synology
Nuss nicht verkehrt.
Und auch von Features her kann man sich nicht
beschweren. Also ein gutes
Gesamtpaket ist das schon.
Natürlich kriegst du es günstiger,
wenn du dich da
selbst damit beschäftigst, selbst was
bauen willst, aber das Komplettpaket kriegst du halt
nicht so ohne weiteres da,
selbst zusammengewurstet. Die haben ja auch
viele Software, die es nur auf Synology Nuss gibt.
Dein Schlafrhythmus ist tot.
Ja, ich hoffe, du musst jetzt nicht gleich
wieder arbeiten gehen.
Kann Windows Server keine Storage Pools?
Keine Ahnung. Ich kenn mich mit Windows nicht aus.
Zumindest nicht mit
solchen advanced Sachen.
Installation complete. Restart. Bam.
Please remove.
Wie ernsthaft jetzt?
Okay, die CD ist doch schon raus.
Hallo?
Okay, also muss man von Hand rebooten.
Fängt ja schon mal gut an.
Alter, ist ernsthaft.
Okay, oh, oh, nice.
Animation hier.
Okay, VMware Tools haben wir schon mal nicht
standardmäßig drauf. Das ist blöd.
Weil, vm...
Warum liefern
so wenige
Betriebssystem-Distributoren
VMware Tools standardmäßig mit aus?
Verstehe ich gar nicht.
Jeder heutzutage probiert doch das Betriebssystem
erstmal in der VM aus.
Dafür Epic Store Werbung gemacht.
Kommt drauf an, was du bewerben willst.
Okay, das heißt, wir müssen jetzt ernsthaft erstmal
VMware Tools installieren, oder was?
Damit wir das ordentlich verwenden können.
Krass, Usability wieder.
Gucken wir mal, ob wir das wenigstens über den
komischen Store von denen installieren können.
Okay, wie macht man hier einen Terminal auf?
So, auch schon mal gut.
vm? Was ist das?
Es ist so was halbherziges an
vm-Werzeugt installiert.
Hm.
Äh, ist aber nicht installiert.
Das brauchen wir.
Und dann müssen wir rebooten wahrscheinlich.
Boah, ja eigentlich
geht's auch ohne.
Wie sieht das bei Zorin OS mit Tablets aus?
Ich hab jetzt kein Tablet
hier, wo ich ausprobieren könnte.
Ah, das sieht doch schon besser aus.
Okay, das erste,
was wir gucken müssen ist,
ob es ein Dark Theme gibt.
Ohne Dark Theme kann ich das nicht benutzen.
Aktuell ist
FTL gratis im Epic Store.
FTL ist ein Nice. Probieren wir doch mal aus,
ob wir uns das hier angucken können mit
Zorin OS.
Gucken wir mal in den Epic Store.
FTL, Epic Store.
Guck mal Leute, FTL, kostenlos gerade.
Endet um 17 Uhr.
Morgen um 17 Uhr.
Also, go, go, go.
Wer es noch nicht hat.
Das ist ein nice Strategy Game.
Okay, also
Knauben fühlt sich halt in der
vm immer hakelig an.
Boah, die Musik.
De de de de de.
Guck mal hier, wie viele.
Warum haben wir eigentlich so viele Dance Emotes?
Würdest du sagen,
dass selbstgebaute Nassurfer verdammt viel
Strom brauchen? Nö.
Wenn du die richtige Hardware auswählst,
hast du
ein Gesamtpaket, was
wahrscheinlich einen Tick weniger verbraucht
und fürs gleiche Geld mehr Performance
bringt als ein Synology Nass. Dafür
auch bei weitem nicht so ein schönes
Gehäuse, beziehungsweise so ein schönes Gesamtpaket.
Wenn man da Wert drauf legt.
Ja, wenn man beispielsweise das
Synology Web in Oberfläche
haben will und sowas. Die gibt es natürlich nicht
zum selbst installieren.
No Paper Jam.
Ja, ich habe die ganzen Emotes schon voll.
Okay, wir gucken jetzt erstmal, wie man Themes
umstellt. Themes.
Zorin Appearance. Okay, man findet
mit, wenn man Themes sucht, schon mal
die richtigen Einstellungen. Das ist schon mal
ein großer Pluspunkt. Okay,
Fenster kann man. Ihhh.
Man kann Fenster nicht
resizen mit Windows
rechter Maus. Das heißt, mit Windows
mittlerer Maustaste ist eh schon mal was.
Ohne das ist Müll.
Okay, also. Wow.
Also, was kann man hier eigentlich themen?
Black.
Ahhh.
Yes.
Dark Theme der Profis.
Das Theme der Profis.
Ja.
Das ist das erste, was mir auffällt.
Die Box passt
nicht. Seht ihr es?
Haben wir eine Bildschirmlupe?
Magnifier.
Ne.
Wie zoomt man unter Gnome?
Zoomt man unter Gnome überhaupt?
Wir müssen nochmal suchen.
Gnome zoom.
Das muss man drücken.
Super alt
plus 8.
plus 8. Wow.
Poggers funktioniert halt auch.
Krasser Shit. Guckte
mal. Seht ihr es?
Da sieht man schon mal,
dass wir die Taste nicht richtig aufgepasst haben.
Super ist die Windows-Taste.
Kann man auf I3 Windows mit
Maus, Rechtsklick, ohne Border
anklicken zu resilen? Jaja.
Du musst Windows-Taste
gedrückt halten oder deine Mod-Taste
auf I3 gedrückt halten und kannst
mit der rechten Maustaste resilen.
Ah. Das ist natürlich schon mal
hier undenkbar.
Sowas hätte es bei Steve Jobs
nicht gegeben.
Der hätte erstmal die Leute angeschissen und dann irgendwie
im Keller verfrachtet oder so.
Wobei
das ja nichts
dagegen ist. Steve Ballmer hätte erstmal
ein paar Stühle nach ihnen geworfen.
Da gibt es ja die Story davon.
Ich weiß nicht, ob ihr die gelesen habt, dass der damals
ein Typ, der bei Microsoft gekündigt hat
und zu Google wechseln wollte,
da ist er quasi hingegangen zu dem, als der
Ballmer noch am Start war, ist er hingegangen
zu dem Typ
und hat
den Stuhl nach ihm geworfen.
Also so
rein etwas
gefährlicher Chef.
Stellt euch mal vor, ihr geht zu eurem Chef
und sagt hier, Chef
ich höre
in drei Monaten auf,
ich reiche meine Kündigung ein, ich gehe woanders
hin und das erste, was der Chef macht
ist erstmal
BÄM, Stuhl in die
Fresse.
Da ist die Anzeige aber raus.
Okay, das mit dem Zoom funktioniert hier schon mal.
Ich meine, das mit der Box triggert ein bisschen.
Aber das letzte, was mir auch
ausprobiert haben, ähm
Pop OS haben wir als letztes ausprobiert.
Pop OS hat das hier
nicht funktioniert.
Das war ein bisschen blöd.
Haben wir es auch
probiert, aber es hat
nicht funktioniert.
So, wie macht man das jetzt wieder zu? Wieder Super Alt 8?
Ah, Super Alt 8.
Was ist denn das eigentlich
für eine absolut
beknackte Kombination?
Das kann sich doch kein Mensch merken.
Hätte man Super Alt und
Z für Zoom oder
irgendwas, aber
Super Alt und 8?
Nein, Deep in OS habe ich aber
auch auf der Liste, das probieren wir mal aus.
Das probieren wir auch noch aus.
So, okay, was?
Updated Software
do you want to install now?
Klar.
Install.
Oh, Grip. Oder nicht?
Ach nee, hier
macht er Updates.
Ich habe schon viele beknackte Keybindings gesagt, Herr Kelmore.
Ja, das
ist leider wahr.
Okay, wie sieht denn der Dateimanager aus?
Wie sieht denn das standardmäßig aus, Leute?
Ah, so ist es
standardmäßig.
Warum haben die nicht das Blau gelassen
und haben das Blau und das Dunkel genommen?
Weil dieser Blauton, der gefällt mir
überhaupt nicht. Der andere Blauton
vom Lightseam gefällt mir
viel besser. Hast du schon den Windows
Modus von Kali Linux gesehen? Nee.
Also nicht ausprobiert. Grau war das
Beste, irgendwie.
Hmm.
Brrrr.
Brrrr. Okay, das sieht
ein bisschen crappy aus, ne?
Shell Theme. Ist das jetzt anders?
Ah, Icons.
Warum
hat das eigentlich keine Icons ausgewählt?
Okay, wir lassen es jetzt
einfach mal so. Ist gut.
Ist gut, ja.
Sondern nicht hübsch ist die Farbwahl nicht.
Da fand ich die...
Was macht denn das eigentlich?
Ah, das ist eine schöne Funktion,
dass das standardmäßig eingebaut ist.
Welche Linux Distribution könntest du
empfehlen bei einem 2 in 1 Convertible
wie zum Beispiel im Surface?
Generell muss man sagen, dass
Touch Input und High DPI
unter Linux so ein bisschen
schwächen sind, ja. Generell
Desktop. So die klassischen
Desktop Sachen. Kann ich dir nichts zu
raten, weil ich es noch nicht ausprobiert habe.
Das ist aber cool, dass sie das drinnen haben.
Da kann man dann sagen, hier mach mal
ab...
Also sprich, wenn ich jetzt sagen würde
hier ist 17.49 Uhr
wenn wir jetzt mal sagen, ab 18 Uhr
machen wir Darkseam.
Das probieren wir mal aus, ob das
funktioniert, Leute.
In 10 Minuten sollte es dunkel werden.
Schauen wir mal.
Was? Moment.
Sunset zu Sun... Ah, okay, das ist, dass man
wenn die Sonne aufgeht.
Okay, wir probieren das mal aus.
Wir lassen das mal so. Mal gucken,
ob es in 10 Minuten dann dunkel wird.
Icons on Desktop. Okay.
Was haben wir anstatt on Desktop? Nichts, ne?
Home
Trash
Das ist für die Windows Leute.
Network Servers. Okay, das ist für alle
Windows Fans, dass das so ist.
Äh...
Title Bar Buttons
Left
Ah, das ist zu minimieren, maximieren.
Okay, jo. Da bin ich mit rechts eigentlich
ganz, ganz einverstanden.
Icons. Layout.
Boah.
Windows Style, wenn man das mag.
Warum nicht, ja?
Es fühlt sich wirklich schnell und
snappy an.
Das ist für die Mac
Fraktion hier. Die freuen sich dann.
Oh, hier. Ui.
Ui.
Ah, das ist mir zu fancy.
Das brauche ich nicht.
Ich meine, ich bleibe immer meine Manjaro mit i3.
Mir geht es ja nur ums ausprobieren.
Ach, hier sieht man, wo was auf ist.
Was jetzt?
Ist jetzt gecrashed?
Habe ich es gecrashed?
Tja, so.
Das ist jetzt halt für die ganzen...
Das ist jetzt halt absolut Windows Style, ne?
Lassen wir es mal so.
Ich glaube, damit kommt man als...
Ich werde ja immer gefragt, so nach dem Motto, was man als
Einsteiger-Distribution empfehlen könnte.
Machen wir jetzt einfach mal Einsteiger.
Okay. Okay, Leute. Es gibt ein Problem.
Es gibt ein großes Problem.
Eins copy-pasten
geht nicht. Eins copy-pasten.
geht nicht richtig.
Das...
Press F. Guck mal, eins.
Und dann will ich eins markieren.
Und es geht nicht.
Ich muss zweimal eins machen.
Ah, das ist natürlich
kritisch.
Kritischer Hase, meine Freunde.
So, restart.
Gucken wir mal, was da rauskommt.
Nachdem es jetzt geupdatet ist.
Die wollen mich von meinen Gewohnheiten abbringen.
Ja, kann sein, aber dafür würde ich mir kein neues
System für installieren, das mich was von meinen
Gewohnheiten abbringt.
Das soll sich eher mir anpassen,
anstatt ich mich dem...
Schau den Kali-Linux-Link an.
Zeit mal her.
Kali-Linux tanzt sich als
Windows 10.
Das sieht aber wirklich ähnlich aus.
Guckt mal.
Das sieht wirklich ähnlich aus.
Geht copy-paste von Windows.
Kann man klar ausprobieren. Ja, funktioniert.
Guckt mal.
Es sieht schon...
Es sieht schon verdächtig...
Es sieht schon... Pass mal auf.
Es sieht schon verdächtig nach Windows aus, gleich.
Hat schon gewisse
Ähnlichkeiten, oder?
Da hat sich aber eine ordentliche Mühe gegeben,
Gnome zu stylen.
Moin, Weizenhainz.
Okay, also bis jetzt gefällt es mir eigentlich
ganz gut, was man bis jetzt gesehen hat.
Resize.
Ah, Resize nur mit so.
So, was gibt es denn hier unten noch?
Wired-Connection-Test.
Äh...
Okay, Restart.
Ach, das ist Netzwerk hier.
Turn-Off, Wired-Settings.
Was ist das? Ah, Lockscreen.
Äh, wie mache ich die Lockscreen
wieder weg?
Ah! Wie mache ich die Lockscreen
wieder weg? Escape.
Enter. Der Zeichen.
Äh...
Hochwischen? Ist das euer Ernst?
Ich soll wischen?
Wischen auf dem Blastraum.
Das ist ja...
Alles wird zum Tablet umgebaut.
Für Tablet-User. Ist vielleicht gar nicht so schlecht.
Aber muss man unbedingt die ganzen
Sachen auf dem Desktop immer weiter ver-Tablifizieren.
Ich bin mal gespannt, ob es in 4 Minuten
dunkel wird. Was haben wir denn hier noch?
Do not disturb.
Jawoll. No notifications.
Select Location. Okay.
Select Location.
60329. What?
Ah, der NumBlock ist standardmäßig aus. Okay.
60329.
Bahnhofsviertel Germany.
Wie wäre es, wenn man die Stadt
mit einblendet?
Ich meine Bahnhofsviertel Germany.
In welcher Stadt wohnen sie?
Bahnhofsviertel.
Da fehlt Frankfurt dabei.
Nein, und in irgendeinem palästinensischen
im Pool wohne ich zum Glück auch nicht.
Bahnhofviertel Germany.
Wie wäre es mit Frankfurt dabei?
Frankfurt? Bahnhofsviertel?
Im Frankfurter Ghetto.
Temperature Unit.
Celsius. Ja, zum Glück ist das schon mal richtig eingestellt.
So.
Und nicht die Noob-Einheiten.
Okay, was passiert, wenn ich nach Frankfurt suche?
Ah, dann findet er es. Okay.
Places.
Was passiert
bei Automatic Location?
Gutes Wetter
braucht kein Mensch, aber wenn man jetzt
hier unten guckt, dann hat man
das Mini-Wetter.
Ja gut, wenn man das braucht.
Gut, das ist jetzt so Spielerei.
Braucht eigentlich kein Mensch.
So.
Wir haben doch noch unsere Linux-Bewertungen.
Bewertungsmatrix
vom letzten Mal.
Mal angucken, was wir das letzte Mal bewertet haben.
Alles.
Äh, Open Recent.
Wo ist, wo ist es denn?
Linux?
Ja.
Also, Noob-Freundlichkeit.
Muss ich sagen, das war noch
von Pop! OS. Alles. Mögen wir mal alles hier weg machen.
Äh, later.
Also, muss man sagen,
Noob-Freundlichkeit
bis jetzt ziemlich gut.
Es ist alles dabei.
Es macht einen recht minimalistischen Eindruck.
Ähm, ich mein, was haben wir denn hier?
Da ist nichts Großartiges dabei, wo man sagen könnte,
ey, das ist jetzt
zu, zu überploated.
Wie viel Energie braucht man
nochmal, um ein britisches Pfund Wasser
um ein Grad Fahrenheit zu erwärmen?
Eine BTU brauchst du dafür.
Das ist die
Big Brain Einheit.
Also, wenn ihr euch nicht verwirren wollt,
rechnet ihr einfach in BTU.
FPS-Counter.
Äh, das ist ein FPS-Counter in der 4M.
Das kannst du, das sagt überhaupt nichts aus
für euch jetzt.
Wirklich gar nichts.
So, Software. Was kann man alles so nachinstallieren?
Okay, nee, erstmal gucken, was haben wir alles standardmäßig drauf.
Accessories. Calculator.
Gut, die üblichen Gnome Basic-Geschichten.
Es müsste übrigens gleich Dark Mode eingeschaltet sein.
Notepad++ kann man
Warum auch immer man unter
Linux Notepad, ich wusste gar nicht,
ob es das gibt.
Es gibt Notepad++ für Linux?
Wirklich?
Es ist 18 Uhr.
Er hat kein Dark Mode eingeschaltet.
Sorry, NOS.
Ach, das ist über Wine?
Das ist über Wine.
Wine, Wine-Anwendung
aus dem App-Store. Oh, jetzt geht's aber ab hier.
Jetzt wird's interessant.
Ähm, so.
Was haben wir denn hier?
Uhren, das hatten wir gerade auf.
Braucht, keine Ahnung, würde ich nie aufmachen im Leben.
Hallo? Warum geht das immer solitär auf?
Äh, Calculator, Files,
Maps.
Maps. Was passiert
bei Maps?
Ah, ja. Genau da sind wir.
Hat richtig reingezoomt. Hier.
Leute, also wenn ihr wissen wollt, wo ich wohne. Hier.
Wie kann man hier suchen?
Ah, ja. Frankfurt Main.
Was auch immer.
Frankfurt am Main.
Jetzt ist es Black. Ha.
Da ist es.
Äh, das fühlt sich ziemlich, ziemlich, ziemlich gut an hier.
Vom rein raus zoomen.
Also fühlt sich ziemlich schnell an.
Ich würde schon sagen, dass das
Das fühlt sich ziemlich native an.
Doch, doch.
Das ist sehr responsive alles.
Falsche Sprache eingestellt.
Ne, Sprache ist auf Englisch.
So, äh, kann man da Satelliten-View machen?
Go to current location.
Location Services.
Reveal.
Das ist ja fast wie unter IOS.
Location Services.
Wo mache ich jetzt Location Services ein hier?
Und du?
Das ist ja wirklich mit...
Die machen das... Sag mal, was ist denn das für ein Kram?
Das ist ein Desktop-Betriebssystem.
Warum muss ich hier so Smartphone-Geschiss machen?
Da bin ich.
Da, Leute.
An der Autobahnausfahrt.
Auffahrt?
Ja.
Jetzt ist es raus, Leute.
Unter einer Brücke, ja.
Da sieht man mal, Leute, was passiert
als Twitch-Streamer,
wenn man nicht regelmäßig darauf hinweist,
dass man mit Amazon Prime kostenlos
subscriben kann.
Wenn man das zu selten macht,
dann landet man da.
Tragisch, ich weiß.
Haha!
TDD.
FitX Twitch Prime.
Dankeschön.
Big Brain Sub.
Jetzt kann ich umziehen.
Jetzt kann ich hier auf...
in die Blume da ziehen.
So.
Das ist relativ sicher.
Das ganze Gnome ist Hardware-accelerated.
Ich kann sie gar nicht dagegen wehren.
Okay, kann man jetzt hier noch umschalten
auf...
Satellitenbilder?
Wie wäre es mal mit einem Hover-Text?
Ah, hier.
Choose Map Type.
Satellit.
Ja.
Guck, da sieht man hier mein Zelt schon.
Da.
Von hier streame ich aus.
Guck, ich habe hier so einen
alten Container.
Da habe ich umfunktioniert.
Zum Streaming
Büro.
Und hier nebendran
ist das Zelt, wo ich drin schlafen muss.
Ah, da sieht man mal wie gut die Satellitenbilder
sind mittlerweile.
Das ist Sorin OS, ja.
Er fühlt sich gut an.
Und das ist Gnome, ja. Gnome in der VM
mit dieser billigen VM-Hardware-Beschleunigung
fühlt sich wirklich schnell an.
Ich bin mal gespannt auf
die Lite-Variante von Sorin OS.
Routenplaner.
Bei Crafthopper.
Das ist ein Service, von dem ich im Leben noch nichts gehört habe.
Okay, wie komme ich
von meinem aktuellen...
Äh. Wie komme ich von meinem
aktuellen Standort?
Genau von da.
Wie komme ich von da nach
Frankfurt auf die
Zeil? Das würde mich interessieren.
Nicht Zell. Zeil.
Äh.
Ach, das war zu Fuß.
Mit dem Auto.
Ja.
Wie wäre es mit Straßennamen
dabei oder so?
Straßennamen?
Wie blendet man da Straßennamen ein?
Weil ohne Straßennamen ist...
Ist ziemlich doof.
Straßennamen in der Übersicht
wären schon huge praktisch.
Mit was virtualisiert? Das ist vor allem bei Workstation.
Kann man das hier in den Settings irgendwie
einstellen?
Das ist glaube ich...
Ne, das ist Mapbox. Also OpenStreetMaps.
Ja, das ist OpenStreetMaps.
Aber der Anbieter ist Mapbox, die quasi als
Zwischen-AP da irgendwie drin sind.
Okay, also Straßennamen kann man irgendwie nicht
einblenden.
Obwohl, ich weiß nicht, ob das doof ist,
weil Straßennamen in so einer Übersicht
wären schon sehr, sehr praktisch.
Gut, die komische Routenplaner-App
werde ich wahrscheinlich eh nicht verwenden.
Okay, gucken wir mal, ob wir
Visual Studio Code installieren können.
Jawoll.
Version.
SnapStore.
Will ich das echt als Snap installieren?
Ja, komm, warum nicht?
Snap ist der Sack, Alter.
Ist das... Das ist Core.
Ich hab mir kein, kein
Ultimate gekauft.
Danach probieren wir nochmal Light aus.
Okay, Install. 1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6.
Huge Passwort. Aber ich muss sagen,
der Eindruck ist insgesamt deutlich
schöner als bei Pop! OS.
Was ist denn das daneben? Ah, Multiple
Desktops. Wie schaltet man denn Multiple
Desktops um?
Shortcut.
Oh ne, das war jetzt...
Das war mein Windows. Gehen wir fort.
Ah, Ctrl
Alt. Hoch, runter.
Warum nicht Windows Alt, wenn das
andere doch Windows Alt ist?
Deine Masterverweiterung für
Visual Studio? Das kommt drauf an, was ich da drin mache.
Also für mich, wenn ich irgendwelche
Microcontroller-Geschichten mache,
Plattformer ja auch, mit Abstand das Wichtigste.
Ansonsten die
C, C++ Erweiterung.
Weil es ja irgendwie,
außer dem Qt Creator, keine gescheiten
C++ Ideen erstmal gibt.
Ähm, also C, C.
C++ gehen wir fort. C++ ist ja...
Ähm...
Ansonsten die Markdown-Extension.
Brauchen wir.
Okay, Launch. Mal gucken, wie es funktioniert.
Okay, geht. Funktioniert
einfach. About-Version ist sogar die
aktuelle Version. Die Version
ohne Santa-Hut.
Gefällt mir schon mal ganz gut.
Fenster verschieben mit Windows-Taste
und linker Maustaste geht. Das ist gut.
Äh, Fenster maximieren.
So geht auch. Ist auch nice. Okay, installieren
wir mal hier. Äh, C++
installieren wir.
Ich will nochmal gucken, ob alles prinzipiell tut.
Ja, ist doch schick.
Ich mein,
dieses, dieses dunkle
Blau auf dem Grau, ich weiß nicht, das ist
so ein bisschen, das ist so Geschmackssache. Wirklich schick ist es
nett, ja. Git-Lens.
Äh,
ist Git-Lens das mit den, mit
den, mit den
Gatter-Einblendungen? Also mit diesen, hier an der
linken Seite?
Ansonsten, ich verwende eigentlich keinerlei
Git-Geschichten im Editor oder in die IDE.
Ich mach das alles über...
Shell. Mal Gnome für Manjaro
probieren? Nee. Ja, das
ist das. Doch, das meinte ich.
So, was haben wir denn sonst noch
standardmäßig drauf? Das haben wir uns schon
angeguckt. Eine To-Do-App.
Das ist wahrscheinlich der größte Crap überhaupt.
Ja, ist es. Ähm...
Äh, what?
Ich hab das überhaupt
nicht angeklickt.
Okay, jetzt wissen wir auch, was die unter
professionelle Bildbearbeitung verstehen.
Gimp. Na gut.
Games.
Eisel. Riot.
Mojang.
Ist das Minecraft?
Mines?
Quadra-Puzzle? Wir müssen
gucken. Das wichtigste Spiel.
Das wichtigste Spiel.
Was wir
brauchen. Moment. Das wichtigste Spiel.
Tux-Card.
Super
Tux-Card. Das brauchen wir. Ganz wichtig.
Ganz, ganz wichtig.
Ohne Super
Tux-Card geht hier nix.
Ist das nicht ein Super Mario unter Wasserlöffel?
Das könnte
sogar Mario Galaxy sein.
Äh, nicht Galaxy, Mario Odyssey
sein, oder?
Mario-Card. Nee, Mario-Card ist es.
Mario-Card ist es.
Ja, also Super
Tux-Card brauchen wir auf jeden Fall.
Mal gucken, ob das in der 4M läuft.
Boah!
Super Tux-Card läuft.
Wie sie laut.
Okay,
wie stellt man die Lautstärke ein?
Okay, was?
Connect? Yes.
Darfst du.
Exit? Wie?
Kann man das nur mit Online-Account spielen?
Nee.
What?
Offline-Account, ja.
Also.
Story-Mode.
Nicht euer Ernst, oder?
Ist das RTX
on, Leute?
Wie sieht es eigentlich mit der Auflösung aus?
Muss ich das jetzt im Fenster spielen?
Was ist das für ein Stumpfsinn?
Huge Story-Line.
Die Kuh ist weg, Leute.
Die Kuh ist weg.
Die Kuh ist weg. Was machen wir jetzt?
Oh, da kommt der Super Tux.
Der Super Tux, wo der Bauch fehlt.
Gott, ist das schlecht.
Oh, Huge Voice-Acting, Leute.
Soll das ein Bowser-Abklatsch sein, oder was?
Ah, yes.
Ein Augenschmaus.
Ein wahrer Augenschmaus.
Excellent Graphics.
Die Gnu-Kuh ist weg, ja.
Wie macht man die Auflösung?
Wie stellt man die Auflösung ein?
Auflösung. Hier.
Options. Graphics.
4 zu 3.
Ist klar.
10 zu 9.
Jawoll.
Fullscreen. Fullscreen.
Oh je.
Hallo?
Nein.
Fullscreen geht nicht.
Aber ich meine, wir können.
Wir können, man.
Oh.
Wahnsinn.
Meine Maus geht übrigens nicht mehr.
Meine Maus ist kaputt.
Die Maus ist weg.
Moment.
Ne.
Die Maus ist kaputt.
Vielleicht muss ich das auf...
Oh.
Ah, jetzt geht's.
Jetzt geht die Maus wieder.
Jetzt müssen wir uns Huge Gameplay angucken.
Ja.
Das geht ja mal ab hier.
Open World Racing.
Huge Open World Racing.
Wow.
Soll man da durch?
Pfeiltasten. Pfeiltasten.
Mal gucken, wo die Welt zu Ende ist.
Ich würde sagen,
hier ist die Welt zu Ende.
Das Auto hat kaum Beschleunigungsgefühl, ey.
Hier ist die Welt zu Ende, Leute.
Vorbei.
Die Welt...
Es ist doch alles recht statisch.
Ja.
Massive Graphics.
Peak Open Source Gaming hier.
Gut, ich meine,
man kann sich jetzt nicht so beschweren.
Es ist komplett kostenlos, aber...
Press Fire.
Fire. Leertasten. Okay.
Normal Race. Novize.
Wüsten Map.
Oh, Gott.
Wir fahren gegen Gimp.
Wir fahren gegen Gimp
und gegen...
Oh, Mann. Alter, das Fahrgefühl.
Das ist ja grausig.
Du kannst nur volle Pulle links, rechts.
Du kannst nicht irgendwie
sanft links, rechts. Das geht nicht.
Wow.
Ach, das war schon das Item, oder was?
Ja.
Also, das ist
eines der Games, was sie bewerben.
Jetzt haben wir einen Klopümpel gefunden.
Nochmal.
What the...
Ah, mit Lenkrad.
Ah, verstehe. Oh, mit Lenkrad geht das natürlich gar nicht.
Okay.
Leute.
Warum hat sich das einfach in Bananen verwandelt, jetzt?
Nach hinten schießen
geht auch nicht. Okay, Leute. Ich will sagen,
Huge Gaming
Experience unterlie...
What?
Absolute Massive
Gaming Experience.
Super Tux Card.
Die haben einen Trailer auf der Webseite, wo das Spiel gut aussieht.
Können wir machen, wenn ich
die Super Tux
Website...
Das... Aber ich muss sagen,
Sorin lässt sich doch intuitiv
recht gut
bedienen, ja.
Gefällt mir jetzt. Gefällt mir deutlich besser
als Pop! OS.
Hast du schon mal versucht, wirklich auf Linux
mit Wine zu zocken? Ja, versucht...
Ich hab immer mal wieder ein bisschen mit rumgespielt und bin zum Schluss gekommen,
dass es sich halt nicht lohnt. Hier.
Super Tux Card 1.0
ist out. Das ist erst dieses...
Dieses Jahr ist es erst erschienen, Leute.
Boah.
So gut sah das bei mir jetzt aber nicht aus.
So gut sieht das
nicht aus bei... Gut, man darf nicht vergessen,
ich hab ja auch in der...
Ich spiel das ja auch in der VM.
Also sprich, in der VM
sieht's nochmal doppelt scheiße aus.
So sieht das ganz gut aus, ja.
Ganz okay zumindest.
Wieso du immer...
Mach mal Ausrufezeichen 1 im Chat.
Da gibt's ne Erklärung zu. Okay, wir geben
der Sache noch... Moment.
Eine Chance geb ich dem Spiel noch.
Und zwar...
Card.
Super.
Warum findet der das nicht?
Der findet meine Games nicht.
Es ist nicht da.
Super Tux Card ist weg.
Da ist es.
Aber im Startmenü
ist es nicht.
Ausrufezeichen 1 ausgeschrieben.
Ich muss jetzt grad nochmal Grafiksettings.
Wir machen jetzt Grafiksettings und nochmal hier
volle Pulle.
Hallo?
Alter,
ich will die Grafiksettings einstellen.
So. Volle Pulle, Leute.
Bessere Grafik geht
in dem Spiel nicht. Apply.
Jawoll.
Jetzt passt auf.
Huge Graphics kommt jetzt. Massive Graphics.
Okay.
Ohne Scheiß.
Es sieht wirklich deutlich besser aus.
Es sieht immer noch kacke aus.
Aber es sieht deutlich besser aus.
Es hat Tiefenunschärfe.
RTX on.
Es sieht deutlich besser aus.
Next Gen.
In Zukunft wird nicht mehr die Frage sein
Can it run Crysis, sondern
Can it run Super Tux Card?
Guck mal hier, wahnsinnig toll
gehighlightene Bananen.
Hab ich überhaupt Gegner?
Ich hab keine Gegner, oder?
Das sieht doch jetzt halbwegs brauchbar aus.
Ich mein, es sieht nicht gut aus.
Es sieht auch ziemlich kaputt aus, was die
Highlights angeht, aber das liegt an meiner 4M.
Das geht doch halbwegs, oder?
Okay. Bäume haben keine
Kollisionsabfrage.
Na gut, wie auch immer.
Wir machen jetzt zu.
Super Tux Card. Gut.
Wichtig, dass das Game dabei ist.
Sonst wüsste ich ja gar nicht, was ich hier machen soll.
Wenn Super Tux Card nicht dabei wäre.
Wir sollten mal RTX On machen
für Super Tux Card.
So, was haben wir sonst noch dabei?
Graphics. Document Viewer.
Gimp.
Naja, wer es mag.
Simple Scan. Shotwell.
Okay, absolut Standard-Kram.
Internet. Remote Desktop
Client und ein Browser.
Okay, das ist sehr minimal.
Office. Kalender.
Jaja.
Okay, halt ein stinknormaler
Kalender.
About.
Wer hätte gedacht, dass der Kalender Kalender heißt?
Ich muss ja sagen, das
Dark Theme gefällt mir nicht so gut.
Das Light Theme sieht besser aus.
Diese komische hellblaue Farbe ist nicht so schön.
Gut, der Rest
ist Office.
Office Crap.
Den keiner braucht.
Nein, ich will nicht lernen, was Neues.
So. Sound und Video.
Müssen wir die Musik wieder anmachen.
Videos.
Rhythm Box. Pity.
Wie, was auch immer das ist.
Irgendwas, was aussieht wie ein Video-Editor
von 1995.
System Tools.
Ja, ich muss sagen, für das,
dass es ein Gnome 3 in der VM ist,
mit VMWare 3D,
läuft das erstaunlich gut und sieht auch gut aus.
Zorin Connect.
Okay, erstmal Power
Statistics angucken.
Ah, yes. Sehr viel Sachen, die...
Oh, Wahnsinnsstatistik.
Ähm...
Zorin Connect.
Connect with your mobile
Device.
Okay, das scheint ganz...
Das heißt, da kann man irgendwie...
Ja, das geht bestimmt nicht mit IOS.
Ne.
War klar, dass das für IOS natürlich nicht funktioniert.
Searching for Devices. Da ist ja keins dran.
Was ist Brasero CD Brennen
Programm?
Ich muss euch ehrlich sagen, es gibt nicht allzu viel
zu meckern. Also, wenn jemand auf der Suche
ist, nach nem
wirklich gut
vorkonfigurierten Ubuntu
mit, ähm,
schneller Oberfläche,
was sich intuitiv bedienen
lässt. Da hatte ich mit Pop OS nur meine
Probleme. Oh, ganz wichtig.
Wie viele Backgrounds sind dabei?
Backgrounds. Zorin.
Ich brauch ein Ayaya-Background.
Moment.
Ayaya.
Mal gucken, wie einfach man
Hintergrundbilder
austauschen kann.
Background.
Okay, wie tausche ich das jetzt aus?
Pictures.
Colors?
Ah, das ist in Download, nicht Pictures. Okay.
Pictures.
Oh, jetzt endlich.
Für die ganzen Weebs unter uns.
Jetzt gibt's mal was für euch hier.
Okay, Hintergrund austauschen ist
ein bisschen schwierig.
Woodface.
Was war Default?
Das da? Ne, das war Default, ne?
Okay, das ist easy. Trash.
Das ist ein ganz normaler Gnome.
Nautilus.
Du bist doch der Größte wie vor allem. Ja, ich hab
in meinem Leben zwei Animes geguckt
oder so. Huge.
Oder ein, oder zwei.
Nee, auf jeden Fall nicht viel.
Ähm, später erinnern.
Das einzige Problem ist,
dass Firefox nicht Darkseemed ist.
Oh, wie?
Warum ist das jetzt auf einmal auf dem Desktop?
Ich hab doch gar nichts gemacht.
Wie kommt das auf dem Desktop?
Erstmal.
Oh, so sieht der Mülleimer also voll aus.
So sieht der Mülleimer voll aus.
Und
das sieht einfach aus wie
ein anderes Album.
Gut, wenn's sein muss.
So, was folgt man noch in unserer Linux-Bewertungsmatrix?
Gucken.
Optik, Look und Feel.
Look und Feel ist gut.
Auch die Shortcuts und sowas.
Aber Optik muss ich sagen, das Dark-Theme
ist nicht so hundertprozentig meins.
Das, ähm, das Light-Theme
sieht ziemlich gut aus.
Leute, Achtung, Sonnenbrille
aufsetzen. Das Light-Theme
sieht gut aus, aber das Dark-Theme ist
mir irgendwie, diese komische, diese blaue
die Schrift und so, das gefällt mir nicht so gut.
Halbes Jahr, POC, no happy meal for you.
Dankeschön. Big brain sub.
Huge, huge sub.
Big prime, big brain sub.
Okay, das hier können wir uns im Prinzip
sparen, weil das ist ein Ubuntu
Ubuntu LTS.
Da wird nicht allzu viel dabei sein.
Gucken wir mal, was für eine Chrome-Version wir bekommen können.
Chrome. Chromium.
Version.
Das ist die aktuelle.
Auch ein Snap, okay.
Okay, gucken wir mal, was da für
ob da theoretisch GPU-Beschleunigung drinne
wär. Wahrscheinlich nicht.
Das ist bestimmt normale Chrome.
Nicht der GPU-Beschleunigungs-Chrome.
Warum Chrome, wenn du Firefox haben kannst?
Weil wir ausprobieren, was alles drauf ist.
Weil es bestimmt genauso viele Leute gibt,
die gerne Chrome verwenden.
Äh, wie ging das? About GPU?
Nee, GPU? Ah, yes.
Hardware accelerated, Video-Decode unavailable.
Okay, das ist zu erwarten gewesen.
Erstens, VM.
Und, äh, zweitens
haben die ja mit Video-Decoding
unter Linux große Probleme.
Mal gucken, wie YouTube läuft.
Schauen wir uns mal
das neuste Max-FPS-Video an.
So, weil da passiert nicht viel.
Ähm, nehmen wir mal
irgendwas in 4K.
So, Battlefield ist immer 4K.
Ah, fast.
Wow, okay.
Zeig mal.
Okay, Hardtop, schauen wir mal.
Wir brauchen dann ordentliche
Sachen. Gut, das ist
ganz normales Debian.
Ganz gute Paketauswahl, ganze Sachen geht auch
schnell. Terminal sieht
standardmäßig okay aus. Was ist standardmäßig
für Terminal? Gnome-Terminal, okay.
So, also
Systemauslastung
halt mega
hoch, dank keinem
Hardware-Decoding. Das war
anzunehmen. Ich bin auch
kein Fan von Snap.
Du kannst ja von den meisten Sachen, also
vor allem Go-Programme kannst du natürlich immer super
als Binary runterladen. Aber bei den
meisten Sachen kriegst du auch noch irgendwelche Target-Sets
und sowas.
Aber der offizielle App, ich nenn's mal App-Store
von denen, der hat halt
viele Snaps drin, also wie es aussieht.
Okay, das ist ganz normale
Geschichte, so wie das unter jedem
Gnome ausschaut.
Was kriegen wir denn hier empfohlen?
Editors Pick.
Ein komischer Videoplayer.
Notepad++.
Das muss ich jetzt mal installieren. Ich versteh
zwar absolut nicht, was
die Daseinsberechtigung ist,
dass man standardmäßig Notepad++
im Wine angeboten kriegt.
Einfach selbst kompilieren
beim Gnome, ist klar.
Brauchst erst mal
fünf Stunden.
Wenn's reicht. Fünf Stunden, 40G Platz.
Zwei Terabyte RAM.
Okay, ich bin mal
gespannt, ob das gut funktioniert. Ich meine,
im Hintergrund installiert der mir jetzt ein Wine?
Installiert man ein Notepad++
im Wine?
Mal gucken, wie gut das funktioniert.
Ich mein, die Daseinsberechtigung
erschließt sich mir noch nicht ganz.
Weil man muss sich mal überlegen,
warum installier
ich mir den Linux
wo es
alles
an Texteditoren und
Geschichten gibt, was ich eigentlich
nur haben will. Warum installier ich mir
dann ein Wine mit Notepad++?
Die
Daseinsberechtigung erschließt sich mir noch
gar nicht so richtig. Okay.
Snap Wine
wird konfiguriert.
Aber eins muss man ihnen lassen, also sie
haben das wirklich sehr
easy gemacht für Leute, die
absolut keinen Plan haben. Und ich mein, da an
Texteditoren, die soll sich ja mitrichten.
Du kannst in deinem
Softwarecenter anklicken, ich hätte gerne
Notepad++ und zack, dann hast du
Notepad++.
Was ist einfacher zu lernen?
App-Programmierung oder Webseiten?
Webseiten. Aber das Schöne ist mittlerweile,
wenn du Webseiten programmieren kannst,
gibt's genug Geschichten, die dich quasi mit
Webseitentechnologie auch Apps programmieren lassen.
Webseiten programmieren.
Native App ist eklig.
Okay, es ist,
es hat eine massive
Geschwindigkeit hier beim Wine
konfigurieren. Ich mein, es könnte daran liegen, dass
ich im Hintergrund ein Battlefield-Video von mir abspiele.
Da ist es.
Ein Wine Notepad++.
Es sieht genauso
eklig aus, wie ich mir das Ganze vorgestellt habe.
Aber es funktioniert.
Poggers.
So, jetzt können wir es wieder zumachen, weil brauchen tun wir es nicht.
Kann man filtern?
Was haben die denn noch für Wine-Anwendungen
drauf? Die Musik ist leicht.
Nervig.
Ah, es ist Kirby's Adventure auf dem Game Boy.
Gut, damals klang das halt so.
54.
Hast du das Video schon so oft abgespielt?
Nein, ich hab nachgeguckt,
weil es drinnen steht.
Wein Notepad++. Okay.
Hab ich nicht gesehen.
Notepad nochmal aufmachen. Ja, okay.
Ich finde es komisch, dass die Sachen hier
im Startmenü... Wir müssen mal neu starten
und gucken, ob die Sachen an dem Startmenü erscheinen.
Activities, keine Ahnung. Wir können das nochmal starten.
Launch. Gut, ich mein, dann mach ich das.
Hat das ein Wine auf?
Och, geht doch.
Das erste Mal hat natürlich länger gedauert, klar.
Aber die Startzeiten für eine Wine-Anwendung
sind okay.
Ähm, was schlägt der mir sonst noch vor?
Klimps. Was ist Klimps?
Ein Gnome Fork.
Warum um
alles in der Welt forkt man ein Gnome?
Ich könnte mir
zigtausend Projekte vorstellen, die ich
lieber forken würde als Gnome.
Nein, nicht Gnome. Was sag ich? Gimp.
Nicht Gnome.
Gimp. Ich könnte mir tausend Projekte
vorstellen, die ich lieber forken würde als Gimp.
Okay, die haben das geforkt,
um es umzubenennen, oder was?
Das ist ja Big Brain.
Ich hab nur Gnome. Ich mein Gimp, nicht Gnome.
Was ist das Problem an Gimp?
Ich mein, Gimp hat den Namen
doch zurecht, also...
Warum mach ich einen Fork vom
Programm nur, um es umzu...
Linux.
Beziehungsweise Open Source Community
auf einen Blick, ja.
Weißt du zufällig, ob man beim
USG Pro 4
einen der LAN-Ports als dritten ablegen
verwenden kann? Nein, hab ich noch nie verwendet.
Die UniFi Firewalls
und UniFi Router-Geschichten hab ich noch
nie verwendet. Ich hab nen UniFi,
äh, ich hab nen Ubiquiti
10G-Switch und
zwei Access Points und halt mein UniFi
Controller. Das war's.
Es ist eine Sprache, eine Beleidigung und deshalb in
Schulen nicht verwendet werden.
Echt jetzt?
Just ma' vier Monate, pock.
Aber richtig pock.
Pogas.
CCTV-Viewer, irgendwie Illuminati
am Start.
Ich würd sagen Überwachungskamera-Viewer.
Na dann nehmen wir doch lieber meinen,
oder?
Also bevor wir das Ding nehmen,
dann nehmen wir lieber meinen.
Meinen Kameraviewer.
Oh, der ist doch schöner, als das
Ding da. Vor allem kann er
mehr.
Naja, wir gucken mal, ob Docker funktioniert.
Docker
äh, hat keine guten Bewertungen.
Wahrscheinlich, weil das System
Docker hoffnungslos veraltet ist.
Screenshot
not available.
Installieren wir mal. Gucken.
Sir of Jelly, Kiwi,
das ist irgendein Python-Ding, keine Ahnung.
Hab ich noch nie verwendet. Ich weiß nicht, ob
Kiwi so ne gute
verbreitete Grundlage ist für Apps.
Ähm, nee, du solltest
Frontend leeren Webseiten. Webseiten,
meine ich
JavaScript, HTML, CSS.
Weil damit kannst du dann auch ordentliche Apps bauen.
Was du im Frontend verwendest,
ist eigentlich ziemlich wurscht.
Äh, was du im Backend...
Manchmal bin ich echt brain-afk.
Was du im Backend verwendest, ist manchmal
ziemlich egal. Im Backend
kannst du Django verwenden, da kannst du Flask verwenden,
da kannst du Node verwenden, ASP, das ist egal.
Also ich würde sagen, du solltest
Frontend erstmal lernen,
wenn du nämlich Webseiten und Apps machen willst.
Weil mit JavaScript und
HTML, CSS, Frontend kommst du
auch ziemlich weit, was Apps
angeht. Ich glaube, die
wenigsten Leute machen wirklich noch so die richtig
Hardcore Native Apps. Die meisten Apps
sind irgendwelche verkappten Webseiten.
Okay, Launch.
Was passiert denn da, wenn ich auf
Launch klicke? Das gibt ja nix, was ich grafisch
starten kann. Launch.
Ah! Oho! Der ist richtig clever.
Guck mal, der macht nen Terminal auf.
Macht nen Terminal auf
und gleich wieder zu. Das ist natürlich
sehr merkwürdig. Wenn ich hier starte,
habe ich eben genau gesehen, es funktioniert.
Aber in meinem normalen Terminal geht
es nicht. Ach ne, doch
hier.
Ne, geht nicht. Wahrscheinlich bin ich nicht,
wahrscheinlich habe ich keine Rechte dafür.
Das ist doof. Das ist schlecht,
wenn man da nicht, wenn die
nicht einen standardmäßig setuppen als Docker
berechtigter User. Das ist ein bisschen
blöd. Also im App Store
sind keine, sind keine Webcontainer
mehr erlaubt. Dafür sind da aber ziemlich
viele
Apptechnologie Apps drinne.
Also ich muss dir ehrlich sagen, wenn
ich, wenn ich heute ne mobile,
ne mobile App basteln würde, dann würde ich wahrscheinlich
mit Flutter probieren.
Weil mir das noch am sympathischsten aussieht.
Aber wenn ich jetzt nur Frontend
Zeugs könnte,
ähm,
dann würde ich ganz klar irgendwas
in der Richtung von React Native,
Nuxt, äh,
Ionic,
Cordova, irgendwas in der Richtung würde
ich dann nehmen. Eindeutig.
Das heißt, wenn man generell Frontend
Gedöns gelernt hat, ist man für Apps auch schon
ziemlich gut dabei. Und man hat
zwei Sachen mit einem auf einen Schlag gelernt.
Die wenigsten, behaupte ich mal, werden heute wirklich
mit äh, Native Apps in Richtung
äh, Objective C, Swift
und, und Java anfangen noch.
Vor allem, weil die App dann halt auch genau
halt auf dem einen Ding läuft.
Wenn man jetzt ne App hat,
die das, die das braucht oder sowas
verwenden will, warum nicht? Aber die meisten
Apps sind, sind, sind
fast schönere Webseiten. Guck dir die YouTube
App an. Die YouTube
App ist im Prinzip auch nur ne schönere
Webseite. Wobei YouTube ist ein schlechtes
Beispiel. YouTube hat noch einiges drumherum.
Ähm,
die Twitter App
ist im Prinzip
auch noch ne schöne Webseite.
Mit ein bisschen Controls drumherum für Settings.
Du bist Native iOS
Swift Developer.
Ich dachte ja nicht, dass es dafür keinerlei Verwendung
mehr gibt. Aber ich glaube nicht, dass die meisten
Apps, äh, heute mit Native Sachen
gebastelt werden.
Weiß nicht, ob es da ne Statistik für gibt.
Zumindest ging's ja auch
gar nicht darum, sondern es ging nur um die Frage, ob man
irgendwelche Python Frameworks für Apps lernen
sollte oder Webseiten.
Und ich bin der Meinung, eindeutig Webseiten.
Ich hab noch nie was Grafisches programmiert,
nur Terminal Sachen. Ist das schwierig mit X?
Ja. X selber
möchte man nicht programmieren.
X selber ist komplett für'n
Arsch. Deswegen
drücken Sie sich auch so lange davor,
rum. Aber Wayland ist
quasi die Todgeburt. Das geht
auch nicht wirklich vorwärts. Also, wir werden
auf absehbare Zeit
mit X leben müssen unter Linux.
Aber
glücklicherweise musst du nicht mehr X selbst
programmieren, sondern
je nachdem
was du machen möchtest und
welche Sprache
gibt's verschiedene Sachen. Aber ich würde dir
zwei Sachen empfehlen. Wenn du
wirklich eine
richtig
gute Desktop App bauen möchtest,
dann würde ich mir Qt angucken.
Das da. Da gibt's auch
ne super IDE zu.
Können wir grad mal installieren
und gucken, ob die dabei ist.
Der Qt Creator.
GTK würde ich dir
wiederum nicht empfehlen.
GTK mag zwar unter Linux und vor allem unter
Gnome ganz nice sein. Da gibt's ja sogar
ne eigene Programmiersprache für.
Aber
Linux ist halt nicht
der Markt, wo du da jetzt wahnsinnig
erfolgreiches
Programm für machen könntest. So Linux Desktop
only.
Also ein bisschen Richtung Cross-Plattform
oder zumindest halbwegs
machbaren
Windows- und Mac-Support.
Vor allem Windows-Support sollte man schon im Auge
haben. Okay, Qt Creator
kann man so schon mal nicht installieren?
Oder bin ich einfach nur zu doof, das zu finden?
Hm.
Creator.
Naja, anscheinend haben sie den wirklich nicht
in ihrem App-Store
drinne. Gibt keinen Qt Creator.
So, ähm,
ich wollte das jetzt eigentlich zeigen.
Das Ding hieß doch so, oder?
Ja, ist er doch.
Alter.
Das ist ganz schön
alt, oder? 452?
Wann kam das raus?
2018.
Okay, das ist ganz schön alt.
Ja, ich installiere mal. Ich kann's
trotzdem zeigen. Ist egal, ob es ein bisschen älter ist.
Erstmal halbes Internet
runterladen. Qt erlaubt,
glaube ich, keinen Zugriff auf Low-Up. Ist klar.
Kannst mit Qt alles machen.
Das ist ein stinknormales CC++.
Du kannst da alles mitmachen, was du willst.
Du kannst sogar X-Server-interne
Sachen irgendwie
tunen,
wenn du willst.
Also, überhaupt kein Problem.
Ähm.
Ja, was wollte ich dir gerade sagen?
Genau. Also, wenn du so auf die
Native-Desktop-Schiene willst,
dann, ähm, auch ein bisschen
Cross-Plattform. Da würde ich mir Qt angucken.
Weil du hast ja auch explizit geschrieben,
du suchst was, was mit X funktioniert.
Also du willst anscheinend was unter Linux machen.
Unter Windows sieht das nochmal anders aus.
Da würde ich jetzt nicht groß mit Qt rumwursten.
Zumindest nicht,
wenn es Native-Windows sein soll.
Gar vielleicht eine Windows-Store-App.
Wer auch immer so verrückt ist,
eine Windows-Store-App zu machen.
Und das nächste ist,
das ist das, was TeamServeJelly auch empfohlen hat.
Wenn du grafische Anwendungen machen möchtest,
ähm, und dich nicht
ein bisschen mit Web-Geschichten auskennst,
ich finde, es ist in der heutigen Zeit
nie verkehrt,
ein bisschen Web-Frontend zu nennen.
Ich meine, guck mich an.
Ich bin bei weitem nicht der krasse Frontend-Held,
aber trotzdem machen wir in letzter Zeit so viel
JavaScript-Frontend-Geschichten,
einfach weil es gut funktioniert.
Weil es überall läuft und weil es klappt.
Und kann man
halbwegs gut
JavaScript, CSS, HTML,
ist das ein
riesiger Vorteil
für weitere Geschichten.
Erst lernt man natürlich was.
Frontend-Web-Frontend-Geschichten braucht man immer.
Und wenn man mal
rüber guckt zu Sachen wie Discord,
die sind auch
komplett mit Web-Technologien
entwickelt, außer mit ein bisschen
Discord hat noch ein bisschen
C-Modules dabei.
Ähm, ich will jetzt
nicht Werbung für noch mehr Elektron-Programme
machen, weil ich meine, es gibt schon genug
Programme, die du startest und 600 MB
RAM verbrauchen, aber es ist zum
Einstieg, wenn man
Richtung Cross-Plattform-GUI-Programme
schaut, leider
oder je nachdem, wie man es sieht,
ich sag mal leider,
eine der besten Möglichkeiten, die man
hat. Ansonsten,
ja, aber Web-Geschichten können ist
auf jeden Fall nicht verkehrt.
Und wenn es Native und C++ sein soll,
dann, ähm,
dann würde ich ein bisschen mit Qt
rumspielen.
Qt hat zwei Sachen, die haben die alten
Widget-Geschichten, das ist so ein bisschen
was wie Windows Forms, alt,
geht, funktioniert gut, sieht aber
scheiße aus. Oder die haben das
Neue, die haben ihre
okay, man merkt dem Ding an, dass es ganz schön
alt ist, weil du kannst
auch gar keine neuen QML-Geschichten
also nicht die neuen
Vorlagen auswählen.
Das ist natürlich jetzt ziemlich doof.
Oh, ich hab keinen Compiler drauf, okay.
Lassen wir das Ganze.
Ja, das ist dann auch noch
eine Variante. Discord sieht
man aber auch an, dass es nicht responsiv ist.
Das stimmt,
aber man darf nicht vergessen,
was man dadurch gewinnt.
Ich bin ja auch kein großer Elektron-Fan.
Man darf aber nicht vergessen,
dass Discord dadurch einfach auf jeder
Plattform verfügbar ist.
Und ich bin mir ziemlich sicher,
dass die
Anwendung in diesem
Umfang, ich weiß
nicht wie groß die
Teamgröße von Discord ist,
aber eine Anwendung in diesem Umfang mit diesen
Features
auf allen, inklusive
Mobile, inklusive Browser,
wäre nicht möglich
gewesen.
Ohne dass sie es auf Elektron-Basis gemacht hätten.
Ich meine, das läuft
im Browser, das läuft
unter iOS, unter Android, unter Mac,
unter Linux, unter Windows.
Das hätten die nie.
Die hätten niemals
Native-Anwendungen mit dem Funktionsumfang
gebaut und der einheitlichen Struktur,
wenn sie das hätten für
...
wenn sie mal mindestens 3,
eher 4 Plattformen entwickeln müssen.
...
Also Elektron hat schon seine Daseinsberechtigung,
ihr wisst ja, ich bin echt kein Fan von,
aber für so was wie Discord ist das toll,
zumal Discord auch noch ein Sonderfall
ist, Discord ist
eine Audio-Videolanwendung
... und Du willst definitiv
nichts.
Audio-Video unter Linux
mit X oder irgendwelchen komischen Farmworks
machen. Das willst Du nicht.
Dasружene ist, dass im Browser
audio video base die sind einfach schon da und die gehen wie sie unter mac
aussieht weiß ich nicht unter windows ist auch nicht schön zumal die audio
video geschichte unten drunter einfach auf jeder plattform komplett anders ist
windows ist ist mit ihrem direct früher was direct show wie heißt denn jetzt
direkt show ist es nicht mehr direkt ich sage jetzt einfach mal direkt show mit
ihrem direct direct x gedöns für audio video linux ist puls audio also
beziehungsweise x und im hintergrund schwebt immer noch so ein bisschen
weiland rum mac ist wie ist das quatsch wie coca und und ich weiß gar nicht wie
die audio video geschichten unter unter audio kit oder audio kit was wir immer
dann hast du noch mal ios was hoffentlich relativ
gut ist und dann hast du noch mal ios was hoffentlich relativ gut ist und dann
ähnlich zu mac os ist das heißt das müsstest du wahrscheinlich nur
teilweise neu machen core audio kann sein ja und dann kommt android noch mal
als zusätzliches system rein was noch mal komplett anders ist also wenn du
das native hättest entwickeln wollen nie niemals nie im leben in dem umfang und
so wie es jetzt funktioniert sir of celly sagt also zuerst mal html css
lernen also von den optionen die du geschrieben hast ja oder direkt
mit flatter sprachen ja moment das jetzt also wenn du wenn du mobile apps
machen möchtest ist flatter auf jeden fall wenn du jetzt quasi einsteigt ist
flatter auf jeden fall nicht schlecht flatter hat zukunft flatter ist jetzt
schon ziemlich beliebt für mobile apps ja eigentlich auch ursprünglich gemacht
flatter geht immer mehr in richtung auch auf desktop möglich flatter ist ein
bisschen nicht futzler ist auch so ein bisschen investition in die zukunft aber
selbst bei flatter ist es nicht verkehrt wenn du ein bisschen html css kannst
auch wenn es anders ist in flatter aber man kann schon so ein bisschen vor allem
halt durch dank dart weil dart ist halt sehr ähnlich zu javascript naja ich nehme
es zurück dart hat ähnlichkeiten mit javascript sehr ähnlich javascript würde ich
nicht sagen ist nicht verkehrt ja und frontend zu können so die frontend basics zu
können javascript html css ist nie falsch
ladder hacken
da kommst du immer mit weiter sondern außerdem kann sie natürlich auch wenn du
sagst ich möchte eine mobile anwendung entwickeln
mit genau diesen sachen kannst du super mobile anwendung basteln sei es jetzt
irgendwie wie gesagt du hast aionic koth dover elektron
native und ganzes geschäft nachts was ist nicht alles gibt
wurde mit mobile zeug apps basteln kannst ja das ist nicht so als wäre flatter
nicht beliebt ja meine hoffnung im cross-platform desktop bereich ruhen ja auch so ein bisschen auf
flatter der grundstein ist gelegt es fehlen immer noch ein paar sachen aber da bin ich
gespannt was wie es nächstes jahr weitergeht ja das ist immer perky agnostik der schreibt
discord hatte in der vergangenheit aber schon genug audioprobleme unter den jungs und jetzt
überlegt dir mal die würden was eigenes verwenden und nicht auf chrome aufsetzen was meinst du was
die dann für probleme hätten wenn die schon quasi als chrome app oder als als chrome im
extra fenster audioprobleme haben ganz davon ausgehen dass das chrome unter linux schon die
gröbsten sachen gelöst hat was es dafür probleme gibt und wenn du da jetzt neu anfangen würde es
darum zu würsteln aber was wie machen die das denn zum beispiel video buffer abzugreifen also
da gibt es da gibt es mehrere varianten wie die das machen könnten ich weiß
es ehrlich gesagt nicht genau wie es discord macht weiß jemand ob
in discord im browser die desktop übertragung funktioniert das dürfte meines erachtens nach
nicht so einfach möglich sein weil du kannst ja von du kannst ja im browser kontext nicht
auf den desktop zugreifen höchstens halt über irgendwelche add-ons funktioniert nicht das ist
sorry noch mal
es das problem geradeaus funktioniert mit extensions ja das dachte ich mir ja also ich
vermute mal dass discord das mit native mit einem date mit der native extension also mit
dem native node.js module oder so macht dass das schon in gewisser weise betriebssystem abhängig
ist das desktop sharing was die eingebaut haben warum musst du immer die 1 löschen
mach mal ausrufezeichen 1 aber ausgeschrieben flatter wie flatter
in 3 biliarden und 0 Updates
wie flatter wie flatter
glück auf sie aus da mag einer praonichs
glück außerdem das beste porte das so gelb
singing
gleichen
uely
ja
ich habe es
geantwortet
akzeptiert
das hat sechs
gut
eine
erst
gestellt
einfach
gezeigt haben vor einem Jahr.
Und das hat erstaunlich gut
funktioniert. Allerdings
gab es halt viele Controls auf dem Desktop
noch nicht, die ich gerne hätte.
Anno, das kann ich mir vorstellen, ja.
Es ist schon gut, dass du das nochmal bestätigst, weil
den Eindruck hatte ich auch.
Ghost Rider, genau das Gefühl
habe ich auch. Für Leute, die
umsteigen von Windows und was haben wollen,
wo sie sich zurechtfinden, macht
das auf mich hier einen echt guten Eindruck.
Ich meine,
ihr wisst, ich komme mit diesen ganzen
fancy Oberflächen nicht klar. Ich bin mein
Manjaro mit i3-WM
gewöhnt, aber alles in allem, was ich hier sehe,
ist das wirklich in Ordnung.
Äh, warum ist das
Dark... Ne, das Dark Theme ist nicht weg.
Was hat er eigentlich unter Programming? Ach, da!
Der Cute Creator.
Ja, und ist das das andere Zeug, was ich
installiert habe, auch hier drin?
Wir rebooten mal, Leute.
Mal gucken, ob es da drin ist.
Äh, Native Desktop Apps. Ich habe es, wie gesagt,
vor einer Weile aus... War absolut
eklig und...
Das letzte Mal, wo ich reingeguckt habe, ist es noch gar nicht so lange her.
Ist immer noch... Ist immer noch nicht schön.
Das Problem, was ich mit Flutter und
Desktop-Apps hatte, dass halt ganz viele
Controls gefehlt haben. Du hattest keinen ordentlichen Webview.
Du hattest keinerlei
Möglichkeit, irgendwelchen, äh,
sagen wir mal, GPU-accelerated Content
da irgendwie reinzukriegen.
Es war noch ein bisschen...
unfertig.
Alter, was geht denn jetzt ab?
Okay, es ist vorbei. Oder nicht?
Ähm...
Äh, Ding.
Was ist das?
Die Musik kommt mir echt bekannt vor.
Es ist nicht Secret of Mana. Es ist...
Was ist denn das?
Ah, genau. Fast.
Ich war nah dran.
Huge.
Ja, das Charakter-Design in Chrono Trigger war von dem
Dragon Ball-Typ. Das erkennt man auch bei dem geblurrten
Bild.
Eines der besten Spiele, die je gemacht wurden.
Äh, nutzt Doreno erst
im Paket-Installer Flatpak?
Nee, das benutzt ganz normal
Ubuntu-Pakete und, äh,
äh, Snap.
Äh, Striker, die feiern sich übertrieben auf der Webseite.
Wir haben uns das ja auch vorher angeguckt.
Es ist an einigen Stellen doch schon ganz schön
hochgegriffen, was sie da erzählen, ja.
Vor allem, make your computer better.
Oder, oder, wo sie hier sagen,
Professional Image Editing, wo ich mir auch gedacht hab, hier.
Professional Photo Editing.
Und dann kommen sie mit Gimp an.
Aber optisch ist es tatsächlich ganz schick.
Manjaro hat mich am Nordplan mit i3 gefragt.
Manjaro i3 ist auch mein absolutes Lieblings, äh,
äh, Kombination, Linux-mäßig.
Kombination, Linux-mäßig.
Pop OS. Pop OS haben wir uns letztes Mal angeguckt.
Pop OS haben wir uns letztes Mal angeguckt.
Das hat mir gar nicht gefallen.
Flutter Web ist doch mittlerweile offiziell supported.
Ja, aber Flutter Web ist doch was anderes, oder?
Äh, das ist...
Das ist die...
Das ist die Sache für Web-Anwendungen, ne?
Ist das diese Web-Assembly-Geschichte?
Magst du, ich hätte noch eine letzte Frage, dann will ich loslegen.
Muss ich jetzt für Flutter JavaScript können?
Checkt das nicht ganz, oder kann ich da Python brauchen?
Äh, nee, nee, weder noch.
Flutter ist, ähm,
Flutter ist, ähm, eine Kombination.
Flutter ist, also, für Apps, wohlgemerkt.
Ich weiß nicht, ob es wirklich so eine gute Sache ist,
also, wenn du noch gar keine Programmier-Erfahrung hast,
weil es die Sache ist, die, wenn du Apps entwickelst,
da ist immer noch ein bisschen mehr, weißt du,
wie erkläre ich das am besten?
Wie erkläre ich das am besten?
Wenn du Mobile Sachen, äh, äh, basteln willst,
dann hast du immer noch so ein bisschen Sachen,
ein bisschen Zeugs drumherum.
Du brauchst entweder einen Emulator,
du brauchst irgendwie eine Debug-Verbindung zu deinem Gerät,
aber, um zu deiner Frage zu kommen,
Flutter ist eine Kombination,
Flutter sind, äh,
sind mehrere Tools.
Flutter ist ein UI-Framework
und quasi Programmiersprache,
da sag ich es mal in einem,
Flutter ist eine Programmiersprache,
ähm, aber das ist quasi, das kommt,
das kommt quasi kombiniert.
Das ist, das kommt kombiniert.
Flutter, Flutter ist das Framework
und Dart ist die Programmiersprache,
aber wenn du Flutter installierst,
das ist alles in einem.
Mach mal Kirby Dreamland,
kann man nachher machen.
Nee, du musst, Dart alleine bringt dir nix.
Dart alleine bringt dir nix.
Du kannst schon mit Flutter machen.
Also, wenn du noch gar nichts gemacht hast
fang an mit HTML, JavaScript und CSS
und baue mal ein paar
paar simple Webseiten.
Das JavaScript-Ökosystem
ist auch total schlecht zu durchschauen,
aber, dein Ziel ist es ja anscheinend,
du möchtest, du möchtest wirklich Apps
programmieren.
Möchtest Apps programmieren.
Und, da ist es halt nicht verschenkt,
wenn du JavaScript, CSS und HTML lernst,
weil es ziemlich einfach möglich ist,
eben mit HTML, JavaScript und CSS
auch Mobile-Anwendungen zu machen.
Flutter,
ist sicherlich nicht verkehrt
für Apps, aber ich weiß nicht,
ob Flutter
die beste Wahl ist, wirklich
mit ganz neu, ganz frisch, ohne
Vorkenntnisse einzusteigen.
Weil für Mobile-Anwendungen gehört halt immer noch einiges drum herum.
Gimp ist gut,
PaintChamp, ja.
Und Dart ist am ehesten wie,
das ist so eine Mischung.
Dart ist ein bisschen so wie C Sharp
plus JavaScript, würde ich sagen.
Ja.
Dart sieht ein bisschen aus wie so eine Mischung aus
C Sharp und JavaScript.
Es gibt aber einen ziemlich guten Flutter
Kurs, habe ich auf, das muss ich jetzt
gerade mal gucken, es gab auf
Flutter
Full Course.
Der da.
Der Kurs ist
ziemlich gut.
Generell sind die Videos von, der heißt übrigens auch
Max, nur mal so nebenbei erwähnt,
sind wirklich gut.
Und das ist wirklich
Oh!
Nice!
Final Fantasy Overworld Theme.
Huge.
Das Video, mach
den Kurs und dann wirst du
feststellen, ob Dart und Flutter was für dich ist,
was Mobile anbelangt.
Danach kannst du auch was. Das ist ein richtig
guter Kurs. Und dann hast du auch
einen, der dir zeigt, wie es richtig funktioniert.
Hast du noch für i3 irgendwelche
Shutdown Restart Shortcuts?
Ja.
Äh, Shift,
Shift, Meta Key
und, und
E.
Aber verwende ich nie.
Einfach, einfach
Streuung Alt F1 Reboot,
wenn es irgendwie hängt, aber es hängt eigentlich nie.
Was? ASMR Keks.
ASMR Keks, ich mach,
habe ich ja schon gesagt, Leute,
bei 300.000 Abos mache ich ein
ASMR Video, aber ich kriege keine 300.000
Abos, weil ich keine Videos aufmache
auf YouTube gerade. Kizuna.
Das wünschen wir dir auch alle.
Der gesamte
Chat auch.
Redi kann man alles machen.
Gibt's, gibt's 1000 Varianten
für Apps. Das stimmt,
Homeworld. Ja, das sage ich auch immer.
Wenn man was einfaches haben will,
wenn man einfach nur, sagen wir mal so rudiment,
was heißt rudimentäre, wenn man einfach nur,
sagen wir mal, normale Anwendersachen
machen möchte, ja,
E-Mails gucken, YouTube
Twitch Chat gucken,
ähm, im Internet browsen,
so, Facebook gucken,
Facebook ist auch so richtig zur
Boomer-Seite verkommen, äh,
Snapchat, Instagram,
was auch immer, keine Ahnung, wenn man einfach nur einen Browser
braucht, ein bisschen andere Programme drumherum,
dann sage ich mittlerweile, Leute, nehmt irgendwie eine Ubuntu-Variante,
nehmt Mint-Linux oder sonst was,
und wenn man
sich wirklich vorhat,
mit Linux zu beschäftigen,
dann probiert zwar mit Manjaro
und i3 oder sowas in der Richtung,
oder Manjaro oder Arch Linux zum
Selbstprogrammieren, äh, nicht zum Selbstprogrammieren, zum
Einrichten, okay, Leute,
hat mir gut gefallen, hat mir besser gefallen als Pop!OS,
jetzt probieren wir nochmal
die Minimalinstallation
aus, achso,
ich hätte es vielleicht ausschalten sollen,
äh,
ah, das ist Fire Emblem, ah, Fire Emblem war nicht
so meins,
das ist Secret of Mana 2, ja,
okay,
ähm,
JavaScript ist gut zum Einstieg, ja, das stimmt,
auch wenn JavaScript jetzt nicht
so die, äh,
aller konsistenteste
Sprache ist, sagen wir mal,
aber es ist auf jeden Fall gut, weil
es gibt keine Sprache aktuell,
die so, ähm,
omnipräsent
überall ist und auch immer, immer mehr
überall Einzug
erhält als JavaScript.
PureOS, nein, das habe ich noch nicht probiert.
Max, kannst du eigentlich Webseiten
bauen bzw. einen Webshop erstellen?
Also einen Shop habe ich noch nie selbstprogrammiert,
wenn ich rein Shop
möchte, würde ich auch mal in Frage stellen, ob ich
einen, ob ich das selbst machen würde, weil
da gibt es, gerade bei einem Shop
gibt es sehr viele Sachen zu beachten,
ja,
dass das auch ordentlich sicher funktioniert,
ähm, da würde ich irgendwas Fertiges
nehmen, okay,
dann stecken wir
mal die CD rein,
virtuell natürlich nur,
Soarin' Light,
Power Up,
Food from CD, try or install,
jawoll, Deadlef,
der Deadlef, Twitch Prime,
Big Prime Sub, Huge Brain,
zwei Monate, dankeschön.
Warum kann ich die Twitch Emotes nicht sehen?
Also wenn du sowas
meinst, wie das hier
zum Beispiel oder
das hier, dann brauchst
du FFZ oder Better Twitch TV,
dass du siehst. Die Standard Twitch
Emote solltest du aber sehen.
Den Soundtrack zu Link's Awakening, ja,
klar.
Eines der drei
Spiele, die ich für die Switch hab,
Xenon 420, Twitch Prime,
auch hier,
Big Prime, Big Brain Sub,
dankeschön.
Porgas,
was ist eigentlich deine aktuelle Meinung
zu Windows 10?
Nerviger, aber notwendiger Scheiß.
Ähm,
okay, Install,
und was ist daran jetzt anders? Sieht genauso aus
wie vorher. Ah,
es ist ein XFCE, eindeutig,
es ist ein XFCE.
Das Vorwand Gnome, das ist ein XFCE.
Das sehe ich an dem
Startmenü. Sieht aus wie
XFCE, ist gar nicht ein XFCE.
Äh, weiter.
Detect Keyboard,
yes, yes,
no,
no French.
Weiter.
Ah, next.
Installieren ist jetzt einfach mal.
Und überschreiben das andere.
Erase and Install, bam.
Next.
Berlin.
Benutzername,
123456, 123456,
continue, sehr schön.
Okay, jetzt kann ich ein bisschen Chat gucken,
während er installiert.
Ähm,
ja, Meinung zu
Windows 10, wie gesagt, Windows 10
ist für mich leider notwendig,
aber
großer
Windows-Fan bin ich ja nun mal nicht.
Ja, also manche Sachen sind halt unter
das einfach Haare strömt.
Zum Beispiel, wir haben ja letztens das ganze
neu installiert,
was du für eine Orgie durchnudeln
musst, bis du überhaupt mal auf
deinem Desktop bist, dass du was machen kannst, ja.
Dann hast du, dass du noch nicht mal
ausschalten kannst. Du kannst nur
einstellen, ich will alles zu Microsoft
schicken oder wenig zu Microsoft schicken.
Du kannst nicht ausschalten, ich will nichts zu Microsoft
schicken, was eigentlich selbstverständlich ist, gibt's nicht.
Und, aber mein größter Kritikpunkt
an Windows ist ehrlich gesagt, dass es
mittlerweile, vor allem Windows 10 ist da ganz
extrem, so unglaublich
zusammengeschustert wirkt. Ich mach mal ein Beispiel,
ja, wenn man jetzt in die Audio
Settings möchte, wo man einstellen kann,
was für eine Abtastrate
mein Audio
meine
Soundkarte verwendet,
was wichtig ist,
wenn ich zum Beispiel per optischen
Kabel an meinem Audio Interface
dran bin, weil
das habe ich glaube auf 48
Kilohertz eingestellt und Windows macht
standardmäßig 44,1 Kilohertz. Das heißt, dass
Sound klingt scheiße. So, um in
diese Settings zu kommen, muss ich
da drauf klicken,
äh, rechts da drauf
klicken, Open Sound Settings,
äh, Sound
Control Panel, dann kommen wir in die alte
Windows Systemsteuerung irgendwie gedöhnt rein,
Digital Audio,
Advanced, und da kann ich's dann
einstellen. Ich mein, der Fuck Microsoft!
Alter, was ist das?
Das findet kein Mensch!
Ja, nächste Sache
ist, wenn man beispielsweise
einfach nur
englische Sprache haben will,
Leute, ich muss mal gleich was essen
nebenbei, wenn man englische Sprache
haben will und
deutsche Tastatur,
bis man das
findet,
zumal die Dinger auch oftmals rumklitschen.
Letztens haben wir's
versucht im Stream zu machen,
wir haben Windows neu installiert und versucht
es einzustellen, du hattest hier unten,
du konntest es nicht öffnen,
du konntest es nicht öffnen, da stand hier
Prozent 1 drinne, anstatt Options,
weil der Button geklitscht hat.
Brauchst man so langsam einen
PXE-Server? Nee, wozu?
Das ist ja alles individuell.
Vor allem sind das Distros, die ich vorher nicht ausprobiert hab.
Was für eine Distro würdest
du totalen Computer-Noobs
für einen alten Laptop
empfehlen? Denke mal, Lubuntu oder
Xubuntu sind nicht schlecht.
Was spricht gegen Windows 10?
Ah, 32 Bit!
Ähm, tja,
ich würd sagen, die sollen's
vielleicht mal echt mit nem...
Ich mein, Zorin OS macht
keinen schlechten Eindruck für Noobs, muss ich jetzt mal ehrlich
sagen. Vielleicht wäre das tatsächlich
ne Empfehlung wert,
was wir hier im Stream ausprobieren.
Ähm, ansonsten würd ich halt sagen,
nimm halt irgendeine
irgendeine Mint-Variante mit Maid-Desktop
oder sowas.
Kann ich dir jetzt nicht so wirklich
ultimativ raten, weil ich das Problem selbst nicht hab.
Also,
ähm, auf dem, auf dem
neuen Laptop von meiner Mutter hab ich, äh,
Ubuntu drauf, schon Ewigkeiten.
Wollte das mal umstellen auf
Elementary, hab ich aber nie gemacht.
Und mittlerweile würd ich's auch nicht mehr machen.
Okay, VMware Tools
sind wieder nicht dabei.
War aber auch zu erwarten.
Jetzt zerlehren wir mal schnell nach.
Äh...
Ach, das sind die Settings.
Open VM
Tools Desktop.
Bam!
So, und dann sollten wir gleich Fullscreen haben.
Es ist eigentlich unmöglich einen Unterschied
zwischen 44,1 Kilohertz und
48, und, und 48 Kilohertz zu hören.
Ja, den Unterschied zu hören
ist, äh, merkst du nicht.
Was du aber merkst ist,
wenn beide Enden unterschiedliche
Settings verwenden,
dann knackst's nämlich wie Sau.
Weil das vom Timing her überhaupt nicht passt.
Mein Audio Interface ist eingestellt
auf 48 Kilohertz.
Wenn ich Windows Sound Settings jetzt auf 44,1
Kilohertz hab, knackt das wie Sau.
Die alten Audio
Einstellungen kannst du mit
MMSYS CPL
Jetzt ernsthaft.
Was ist das für ein Stumpfsinn?
MMSYS
Was? CPL.
Alter, Windows,
die können mich mal.
Die können mich mal sonst wo bei Microsoft.
Damit das fange ich
das merke ich mir nicht. Aus Prinzip.
Aus Trotzreaktion merke ich
mir das nicht.
4 Monate, 4 Monate.
Dankeschön.
Huge IQ Sub.
MX Linux haben wir auch mal ausprobiert im Stream.
Hat mir von der Oberfläche überhaupt gar nicht gefallen.
Welche Addons waren das nochmal
für die Twitch Emotes?
Das waren, können wir gleich mal im Browser
hier ausprobieren.
Hallo, Firefox, aufgehen.
Das ist entweder dieses Addon.
Das da.
Oder das da.
Ich verwende das da mittlerweile.
Äh.
Den amerikanischen Tischtennisverband wollte ich jetzt eigentlich nicht aufmachen.
Das da meine ich.
Das da.
Ich finde das hier schöner.
Äh.
Emotes können sie glaube ich mittlerweile von beiden.
Beide von beiden.
DEV MGR MSC
für den Geräte. Alter.
DEV
MGR.MSC
Ne.
Ach ne.
DEV
MGMT
Oh.
Meine Güte, ey.
Windows.
Alter, was ist das für ein Gepiepse?
Ja, auf meiner.
Das ist traurig, dass man sowas braucht schon.
Aber gut zu wissen.
Es wird der Tag kommen, wo die alten
Windows 7 Menüs weg sind und es nur noch Trash Settings
gibt.
Das wird der Tag kommen, wo Microsoft sich
auch mal jemand anderes suchen kann,
der ihren Crap installiert.
Zumal, man hat das mit Windows 8 gesehen
und dem, ähm,
dem Startmenü.
Das erste, was es unter Windows gab, war
Wie hieß das?
Windows Startmenü
Alternative
Ähm.
Classic Shell.
Der Zimtraucher.
Twitch Prime. Huge Brain. Dankeschön.
Die Witcher Serie habe ich nicht angeguckt.
Ne.
Twitch Coins.
Ähm.
Das ist die ganz normale Twitch-Seite.
Also alles, was auf der Twitch-Seite funktioniert,
funktioniert in FFZ und bei der Twitch-TV auch.
Das ist ein Addon, was einfach
die normale Twitch-Seite modifiziert.
Der Rest bleibt gleich.
Wann kommen neue Emotes?
Muss ich mich echt drum kümmern.
Welche Linux-Distribution hast du bisher bewertet?
Oh, da liegt immer so viel Zeit dazwischen.
Also an Pop!OS kann ich mich noch erinnern.
MX Linux haben wir auch gemacht.
Wir haben uns auch mal irgendeine aktuelle
Variante angeguckt. Was hatten wir noch alles?
Ich würde mal sagen, so fünf, sechs Sachen hatten wir.
Ist nicht so, dass ich das jetzt jeden zweiten Tag mache oder so.
Äh. Oh, wie das ruckelt.
Alter.
Guckt euch das mal an.
Guckt mal, wie das hinterher zieht.
Das ist jetzt aber Sequel of Mana.
Jawoll. Beste.
Oh. Alter.
Das kann man nicht verwenden.
Das, das ist...
Aber es ist schneller. Man merkt, dass es schneller ist.
So blöd sich's anhört. Also die Sachen gehen alle deutlich
schneller auf und zu.
Okay, mal gucken, mal gucken, wie das mit
einer anderen Anwendung aussieht.
Mit dem hin und her ziehen. Ja, let's go shopping.
Ja, oh Gott. Das zieht alles eklig
hin und her.
Man kann doch bestimmt in XFCE
3D-Geschichten abstellen, oder?
Appearance.
Hallo? Mein Startmenü ist gecrashed,
Leute. Appearance.
Es ist sehr verwirrend,
dass man hier die Sachen doppelt und
dreifach drin hat, ehrlich gesagt.
Theme. Black.
Theme. Black. Theme.
Warum gibt's das
hier doppelt?
Zorin Dark. Zorin Blue Light.
Zorin Green Dark.
Ach, das ist genau das gleiche, was man hier
drinne auch... Zorin 95.
Oh ja. Unbedingt.
Okay, man merkt schon, dass die XFCE
Distribution schneller ist,
aber das Nachziehen der Fenster
ist eklig. Kann man in
XFCE nicht irgendwie dieses
Composite oder
irgendwelche
Settings, irgendwelche
versuchten 3D
Sachen einfach deaktivieren?
Was hast du für Geschenke verteilt
und was hast du bekommen?
Ist nicht so spannend, dass ich da jetzt
kurz was erzählen könnte.
Das Interessanteste, was ich verschenkt habe, glaube ich,
war eine Custom-Handy-Hülle von
die mich gleich mal
gescamt haben. Ich habe hier eine
Custom-Handy-Hülle designed.
Ist eigentlich ganz nett, aber die haben mich gleich mal
gescamt.
Die haben mir nämlich angeboten, eine
ähm
Premium-Geschenk-Box
beim Checkout.
Die haben sie dann wahrscheinlich nicht mehr drinnen, ne?
Deluxe-Box.
Ja, das Ding. Das hieß mal noch
vor ein paar Tagen, hieß das Premium-Box, ne?
Und wenn man sich das so, also ich meine, Leute,
6,95 Euro.
So, und wenn man sich das so anguckt, denkt man sich
eigentlich, das ist halt so
ein
Hardcase oder irgendwie sowas, ne?
Ich meine,
es sieht nicht billig aus. Es sieht eigentlich
ganz okay aus.
Es ist nette Verpackung, da muss ich es nicht
verpacken.
Und wisst ihr, was es ist?
Es ist ein halb verkratzter
Papp.
Halb verkratzte
Pappschachtel.
Für 6,95.
Voll für den Arsch, ey.
Gleich scamast.
Richtig scamast.
Okay, XFC ist definitiv bei denen
in der Distro nicht so aufgeräumt wie Gnome.
Ich finde gar nichts.
Window Manager Tweaks.
Ich glaube, da müssen wir hin, hm?
Ich vermute mal, wir müssen unter Window Manager Tweaks.
Ne, ich habe keine Ahnung, wo ich
diese Möchtegern 3D
Geschichte ein- und ausschalten kann.
Composite, ja.
Ah! Jetzt ist es schnell.
Nur, dass die anderen
Fenster übelst rumspacken.
Wenn man das ausschaltet.
Na toll. Ich habe jetzt die
Auswahl zwischen Fenster, die rumspacken
oder Anwendungen, die rumspacken.
Toll.
Hat mir die Gnome-Variante als besser gefallen.
Hat sich richtig gelohnt,
die Pappschachtel, ja.
MX-Linux hat mir nicht gefallen.
Aber ich muss sagen, MX-Linux hat sich ziemlich schnell
angefühlt. Tja, dann doch
lieber Windows. Ne, ich schalte
einfach auf mit Majaro mit i3-WM
um.
Und da ist alles gut und alles schnell und alles top.
Okay, vielleicht, wir machen mal
ein paar Optionen aus, ob es dann besser wird.
Okay, das ist in der
VM nicht benutzbar.
Das ist in der VM nicht benutzbar.
Das können wir gleich ausmachen.
Huge Suck.
Leute, ich muss was essen. Ich habe übelst Hunger.
Soll ich ausmachen oder soll ich euch
ins Ohr schmatzen?
So, mal zum Vergleich jetzt.
Nachdem wir sehr viele
Desktop, schön
gestylte Desktops gesehen haben,
gucken wir uns jetzt mal zur Abwechslung
meine Standard
Majaro
Arbeits-VM an.
Ich schmatze euch nicht ins Ohr. Ich mute mich einfach.
kurz, wenn ich abheiße.
So, so sieht mein,
so sieht meine Standard Arbeits-VM aus.
Was hatten wir hier in Windows
95 denn drinne?
Oh.
Gibt's gar nicht mehr.
Nix los hier. Top 1 Streamer auf Twitch.
Wat? Du meinst auf
Wissenschaft und Technik, ja.
Ach, das Browser Windows 95, ja.
Oh, der Browser ruckelt, weil ich erstmal
alles laden muss wieder.
So, jetzt geht er. Ha? Das ist so
meine Standard-Arbeits-Geschichte.
Was geht denn da oben eigentlich ab?
Das liegt an
Visual Studio Code,
was zu lange offen war.
Ach so.
Ja, das ist gut.
Okay, Visual Studio Code
spackt rum. So.
Und so arbeite ich normalerweise, ja. Also ich hab
mehrere Desktops, die
ich durchschalten kann. Also eigentlich
verwende ich nur 1, 2, 3. 4 ist bei mir
so ein temporärer Desktop, wo ich mal irgendwas aufmache.
Ähm.
Was ist
ein WiFi-Client? Das ist
Arduino. Das ist Arduino
Gedöns.
Kann man zumachen.
Das ist für meine Weihnachtsbaum-LED-
Steuerung. Für die hier, guckt.
Oh, das ist
so schön schnell im Vergleich
zu dem anderen Kram.
Das, was ihr den Source-Code, den
ihr da gesehen habt, der ist Teil von meiner
Weihnachtsbaum-Steuerung.
Wobei,
ich lass mich einfach selbst mal zu Wort kommen,
da muss ich das nicht nochmal zeigen.
Weihnachtsbaum, ja.
Ist eher so ein Busch.
Netzteil. Und wenn das Netzteil drinnen ist,
dann leuchtet es rot,
bis er WLAN-Verbindungen hat und
dann geht er an.
Und da hab ich verschiedene Modi einprogrammiert.
Das ist standardisch so ein Kerzenmodus.
Ich geh mal ein Stückchen weg.
Also ich glaube, man erkennt das vielleicht.
Wohlgemerkt.
Der Weihnachtsbaum
hat WLAN dadurch, ja.
WLAN-Weihnachtsbaum.
So ein bisschen pulsiert und
dass jede LED randomized so ein bisschen
eigenen Farbwert
drin hat.
Was hat die Mutter dazu gesagt? Die fand das toll.
Guck mal, sogar mit Webinterface, wo man steuern kann.
Die Webseite sieht kacke aus,
aber muss ja ordentlich gut aussehen.
Man kann den in den Kerzenmodus versetzen.
Man kann den in
hell und bunt, wenn man bunt macht,
dann sieht das Ganze dann
so aus.
Das ist Silvestermodus.
Oh, jetzt ist es wieder.
Der Zoom ist wieder weg, Leute.
Ich kipp das mal.
Und jetzt kann man noch umschalten in
wenn sich
das Ding fokussiert.
Jetzt kann man noch umschalten in hell.
Dann ist einfach nur
einfach nur weiß. Und man kann hier umschalten in
unten noch mit dem Plus und Minus,
wenn man das irgendwie
sehen würde.
Mit dem Plus und Minus kann man noch die Helligkeit machen.
Ich gebe mal wieder auf die Kerze.
Das ist kein Weihnachtsbaum, das ist ein Weihnachtsbusch.
Zack, haben wir wieder
volle Weihnachtsbeleuchtung.
Und das coole ist, dass die
LED-Lichterkette,
die hat... Ja, leider hat
Twitter das nicht länger gecheckt.
Ähm, Informatik
sagt, nice, geht das nächstes Jahr auf den Markt.
Ich kann den Sketch
höchstens irgendwo hochladen, aber da ist
nicht so viel kompliziertes dran.
Ähm,
auf Reddit haben wir gesehen, ja, dass auf Reddit
haben wir uns angeguckt, wo einer Snake gespielt hat.
Guckt es euch an.
Snake auf dem Weihnachtsbaum.
Das ist next level, ey.
Mach nächstes Jahr auch.
Dieses Jahr muss es leider bei
LED-Steuerung mit einem
ESP32 bleiben.
Ähm, hat der Baum
auch einen eigenen Brandmelder?
Was?
Äh, wegen Brandschutz.
Das braucht 0,3 Watt pro LED.
Was soll da groß brennen?
Wir können uns noch mal ein paar Github...
Wir können uns noch mal ein paar Github-Trending angucken.
Was es da aktuell
Interessantes gibt.
Ja, aber nochmal, um nochmal kurz
die Sache abzuschließen mit Sorin OS.
Also das ist ja der Vergleich zu dem,
wie ich halt sonst
normalerweise unter Linux arbeite.
Das sieht bei mir auf der Arbeit fast ganz
genauso aus.
Ich habe ziemlich ähnliche Configs hier in der
VM, wie ich auf der Arbeit habe, also
ist nicht viel Unterschied.
Gleiche Desktop-Anzahl, gleiche
Desktop-Aufteilung. Ähm,
ziemlich ähnliche Bar,
ähnliche Programme, die drauf sind.
Der Unterschied ist bei mir, dass ich halt
daheim Windows habe,
mit einer Linux-VM, dank Video
und Spielen und sonst was. Und auf der Arbeit
habe ich halt komplett Linux installiert auf dem Notebook.
Hätte ja gedacht, du hast so einen
Weihnachtsbaum. Ich mach das jetzt mal auf.
Wenn es jetzt Porn ist, muss ich dich bannen.
Und, ähm,
das Wort löschen. Also ich hoffe mal nicht, dass es Porn ist.
Für uns alle.
Ah, ist es
nicht.
Oh, das ist gut, das gefällt mir.
Das gefällt mir, das hat was.
Alle Cisco-Switche.
Es ist, es ist, ich weiß nicht,
es sieht hässlich wie die Nacht aus, das Ding, ja.
Aber es hat irgendwie was.
Wer zündet als Investor seine Raketen
auch mit einem Arduino?
Das wäre, das wäre tatsächlich, äh,
excellent.
Exquisite-Fivehead wäre das.
Das ist auch so ein Satz, den kann man nur auf
Reddit, äh, nur auf Twitter bringen.
Alter, nur auf Twitch bringen!
Oder?
Excellent-Fivehead. Das, das checkt, das ist doch
so, das kapiert doch weltweit niemand.
Außer Leute, die Twitch gucken.
Moin, kann mir jemand einen
Router, sorry Cisco-Leute,
Router, für einen
KVDSL-Telekom-Leitung empfehlen.
Ein analoges Telefon muss noch dran.
Weißt du was? Kauf dir einfach ne Fritzbox.
Es gibt, glaube ich,
nix, was so easy
einzurichten ist und einfach funktioniert.
Vor allem an einem Telekom-Anschluss wie ne Fritzbox.
Das sag ich als sehr technik-affiner
Mensch, ja.
Aber hol dir einfach ne Fritzbox.
Was für ein Arbeits-Notebook hast du? Das ist
irgendein, irgendein Lenovo
boah, T,
ich hab keine Ahnung.
Weiß ich nicht.
Warum ist eigentlich die Musik aus?
Das ist ein Syncpad T,
ja, ich weiß aber nicht welche.
T450, T480 kann's schon
sein, ja. Es hat auf jeden Fall
vier Kerne. Vier Kerne, die
meiner Meinung nach ein bissl langsam sind.
Dafür hat's ordentlich RAM und ne SSD.
Du kannst dich sogar mit deiner Fritzbox
per SSH verbinden.
Als wäre jetzt SSH-Verbindung
irgendwas tolles. Ich kann mich sogar auf meinen
Staubsauger mit SSH verbinden.
...
Und das ist kein Witz. Alle, die öfters
den Stream gucken, wissen, dass es stimmt.
Staubsauger SSH
ist das Beste.
Und dann seid ihr 2019 im IoT-Zeitalter
angekommen, wenn ihr PSSH auf euren
Staubsauger könnt.
Die Steckdosenleiste hat
kein SSH.
...
Leider, leider kein SSH.
Aber die
Steckdosenleiste hat ein Web-Interface.
Ist doch auch schon mal was, oder?
Die Steckdosenleiste hat kein SSH,
aber die Steckdosenleiste hat ein Web-Interface.
Aber natürlich nur mit der Custom-Firmware drauf.
IP liegt.
Oh fuck. Oh nein!
Kannst du auch mit deiner Toilette
machen. Meine Toilette ist leider ein bisschen alt.
Die hat irgend so ne nicht-dokumentierte,
nicht-genormte Hersteller-Schnittstelle,
nur wo ich keine Ahnung hab, wo ich da was
abgreifen kann.
Also hier, der da.
Der da.
Eine sehr reelle Schnittstelle.
Also der Klo hat leider nur
hier neben...
Gibt's da irgendein Bild, wo man das sieht?
Der hat hier
neben so ne Schnittstelle, auf der anderen Seite.
Das ist die Seite,
das ist die Seite, wo man
mit den Settings,
also das ist die Seite, wo man
Wasser anmachen kann,
Belüftung anmachen kann, Föhn anmachen
kann und Wasser, Wärme, ganzen Geschiss.
Aber auf der anderen Seite
ist, hier ist die Fernbedienung dazu,
auf der anderen Seite hat das Ding
irgendeine Schnittstelle
vom Hersteller.
Und...
Ein K? Ne, das kostet noch ne ganze Ecke mehr.
Ähm...
Aber man sieht's hier leider nicht. Zumindest
ist es leider zu alt, ich kann davon nichts
gescheit abgreifen. Aber...
Big Brain
war am Werk.
Ähm...
Und zwar...
Ich hab mir überlegt,
ob man an die Buttons... Gibt's das hier
vielleicht mal in etwas höherer Auflösung,
dass ich auch mal was kurz zu zeigen kann?
Gut, hier neben hat das Ding nämlich zwei LEDs.
Eine LED für Störung und
eine LED für Abluft
ist an.
Ich wollte da einen
ESP8266 dran machen,
mit so einem Fotoresistor,
der quasi kontrolliert, ob
einer der LEDs an ist.
Und wenn einer der LEDs an ist, weiß ich
entweder, das ist die Lüftungs-LED, das heißt
es sitzt jemand auf dem Klo,
oder es ist die Fehler-LED,
oder es macht das Klo irgendwie einen Fehler
und braucht neues...
Dings...
Reinigungsmittel.
Oder einen neuen Filter, der nachgefiltert werden muss.
Da hab ich mir überlegt, man kann bestimmt das hier unten
abmachen. Das heißt, ich könnte im Prinzip
da irgendwie einen ESP...
Controller reinlegen und
hier neben mach ich dann halt
ein paar Kabel hoch für die LEDs.
Hat Max kein Content mehr,
oder warum redet er über das Klo?
Ja, das...
Kann man so und so sehen, ja.
Ich hab noch so viel Content, aber der Klo ist jetzt
wichtiger.
Manch einer würde vielleicht jetzt sagen, Scheiß-Content.
Ich will nicht was in mein Klo legen.
Ich will was unter die Abdeckung
von meinem Klo legen.
Die Frage ist, warum er so ein Klo hat.
Weil das richtig geil ist.
Leute, das ist
richtig geil.
Das ist die beste
Investition, die ich getätigt hab mit
meiner Kohle die letzten 15 Jahre.
Dieses Klo zu holen,
das ist nicht unbequem.
Das ist einfach nur relativ groß.
Die Kloschüssel
ist exakt eine ganz normale
Kloschüssel, wie man das
kennt. Da ist überhaupt kein Unterschied.
Nur, dass die Beschichtung richtig
gut ist. Das heißt, es bleibt keine
Kacke hängen, weil
High IQ Beschichtung
und man kann sich den Hintern abspülen
lassen, was sehr angenehm ist.
Den Föhn verwende ich nicht.
Hat das Sitzheizung?
Ne, es hat keine Sitzheizung.
Aber es hat eine Wasserheizung.
Also sprich, man kriegt nicht mit kaltem Wasser
den Hintern abgespült.
Da habe ich mir jetzt noch
nicht im Detail so die Gedanken
zugemacht. Vor allem
weiß ich nicht, ob das das richtige Thema für
den Twitch Chat ist.
Endlich ein neues Emote.
Lul weh.
Neue Emotes.
Soll ich mal gucken, wie viele Emote Slots
ich schon habe?
Dass ich weiß, wie viele Emote ich mal über Fiverr
bestellen müsste.
Oh, das Dashboard sieht anders aus.
Fuck. Ach du Kacke.
Oje, wo sieht man das?
Boah.
Okay Leute, ich habe keine Ahnung, wo man das
einstellt mehr. Partner, hier.
Emotes.
Okay, ich habe jetzt
4 Emotes drin und ich habe
insgesamt 1, 2,
3, 4, 5, 6, 7, 8,
9, 10, 11,
12, 13, 14,
15, 16, 17, 18
plus 2
tier 1, tier 2
20 Emote Slots
und ich habe 4 Emote drin.
Okay, das ist echt Fail, Max.
Das ist echt Fail.
Ich muss mal wirklich ein paar Fiverr Jungs
beauftragen und Mädels.
Fiverr und Fiverrinnen
beauftragen
ein paar neue Emote zu machen.
Das geht ja nicht an, dass wir 20 Emote Slots haben
und ich habe hier irgendwie nur
4 Emote drin.
Also, da kann man nichts sagen.
Emote sind schon ein Big Brain,
die wir drin haben.
Also, also Wub S
ist ja mein persönliches Lieblings Emote.
Und Wub Old.
Wub Old ist auch geil, aber Wub S
finde ich gut. Das sind keine
Better Twitch TV Emotes.
Wub S ist handgefertigt
von jemand hier aus dem Stream.
Ich weiß nicht mehr, ich glaube, dass Serious Max war es, oder?
Handgefertigt hier aus dem Stream.
Wub großes S.
Okay, also was trendet denn
auf Github?
Das haben wir schon eine Weile nicht mehr geguckt.
Was trendet denn? Aber Leute, ich habe Hunger. Ich muss was essen.
Drei Stunden.
Alter, wie lange war ich heute
morgens 2,5 Stunden,
jetzt 3 Stunden.
Hört ja gar nicht mehr auf.
Da gehen die Streams hier Schlag auf Schlag.
Okay.
Ich esse mal
nebenbei was. Also ich mute mich mal ab und zu mal.
Wir machen jetzt keine ASMR
Eating Sounds.
Was sehe ich da?
Es gibt ein Frontend Framework von Tencent.
Ist da die China Spyware schon drin?
Beziehungsweise
der Call of Duty
Mobile Shop.
Tencent Hippie.
Cross Platform Framework
Design for Web Developer.
Moment.
Es ist C++.
Alter, was ist mit den Chinesen los?
Okay.
Introduction Video.
Ah, yes.
Moment.
Wir gucken uns das Introduction Video kurz an.
Ah.
Excellent.
Exquisite.
Framework.
Huge Framework.
Hm.
Hm. Hm. Hm. Hm. Hm. Hm. Hm. Hm. Hm. Hm. Hm. Hm. Hm. Hm. Hm. Hm. Hm. Hm. Hm. Hm. Hm. Hm. Hm. Hm. Hm. Hm. Hm. Hm. Hm. Hm. Hm. Hm. Hm. Hm. Hm. Hm. Hm. Hm. Hm. Hm. Hm. Hm. Hm. Hm. Hm. Hm. Hm. Hm. Hm. Hm. Hm. Hm. Hm. Hm. Hm. Hm. Hm. Hm. Hm. Hm. Hm. Hm. Hm. Hm. Hm. Hm. Hm. Hm. Hm. Hm. Hm. Hm. Hm. Hm. Hm. Hm. Hm. Hm. Hm. Hm. Hm. Hm. Hm. Hm. Hm. Hm. Hm. Hm. Hm. Hm. Hm. Hm. Hm. Hm. Hm. Hm. Hm. Hm. Hm. Hm. Hm. Hm. Hm. Hm. Hm. Hm. Hm. Hm. Hm. Hm. Hm
Die schreiben Source Code auf Chinesisch, echt?
Oh, wo war das?
Hier?
Moment, Moment.
Also das könnte man, wollte ich, Hotnet, ja, das könnte echt mein neues Lieblingsframework werden.
Aber das ist sowas von Chinesisch.
Wo hat man es denn gesehen mit die Coden auf Chinesisch?
Hippiekuku, Hippiekuku.
Ja.
Ja, Const Deep Link, nee, nee, nee, nee, das ist, äh, das ist Englisch.
Da.
7000.
Nee, das ist, das ist nicht Chinesisch.
Hier, Const Deep Link, Item, Scan, If PIC ist Installed.
Oh, was waren, was können die Schweine dafür denn jetzt?
SDBA 42, Big Prime Sub, huge.
Dankeschön.
World Encode?
Ähm, das ist C++?
Ja, das ist C++.
Anti-Tech-Gear Stufe 1, dankeschön, nice.
Big Brain, High IQ Sub.
Das ist der Spy-Vicode, Code.
Immer diese Vorurteile hier, Leute.
Wir sind in der Zeit, in der wir in der Zeit sind, in der Zeit, in der Zeit, in der Zeit, in der Zeit, in der Zeit, in der Zeit, in der Zeit, in der Zeit, in der Zeit, in der Zeit.
Ah, yes, yes, yes, alles klar.
Upload a Pen.
How come in Grail?
Hippie.
Die, ähm, Sound-Lippen.
Synchro ist nicht so ganz...
Da hat er gerade gesagt, Hippie ist jetzt auch on GitHub.
Ihr könnt das ja mal ausprobieren.
Hat er gerade gesagt.
Oh, da ist Hippie.
Across-Platform-Framework-Design for Web-Developer.
Okay, es ist...
Ich hab nicht so genau, was es... gecheckt, was es ist.
Ist es ein C++-Web-Framework?
Oder...
Ist es ein Cross-Platform-App-Framework in C++, was sich an Web-Developer richtet?
Examples.
Oh, oh!
Eine Hippie-View-Demo.
Okay, es ist JavaScript.
Hippie-Demo-Xcode.
Punkt M?
Was ist denn Punkt M?
Bitte schön, für eine Sprache.
Objective-C?
Oder was ist denn Punkt M?
Ist es Objective-C?
Module?
Ah!
Ups!
Das wollte ich gar nicht abspielen.
Wie sind wir jetzt auf das Flutter-Tutorial gekommen?
Das M ist für Malware.
Ah, der Chat.
Das ist irgendeine iOS-Sample.
Okay, es ist anscheinend...
Es ist anscheinend ein App-Framework, was sich an Web...
Ein C++-App-Framework, was sich allerdings an Web-Entwickler richtet.
Also im Prinzip ein bisschen sowas wie Ionic oder sowas.
Oh, Andi Teschke, ja, dankeschön.
Er hat Pluton...
Was?
Plutonan ein Stufe-1-Abo geschenkt.
Dankeschön.
Big Brain, Big Gift.
Vergiss das Prime.
Dankeschön, nice.
Ich hab mein Brötchen zur Hälfte runtergeschmissen, wartet mal.
Okay, und man...
Noch ein weiteres Cross-Plattform-Java-Skript.
Ja, aber...
Komm, vielleicht hat's hier irgendwelche Vorteile.
Ich kann's euch leider nicht sagen, weil...
Okay, okay, das kommt nicht in Englisch.
Officially supported Web-Frameworks like React and Vue, same API for different platforms.
Ja, das ist sowas wie Ionic oder Cordova oder sowas in der Richtung.
Flex-Layout-Engine.
Das ist, wisst ihr, was ein bisschen doof ist an iOS-Apps?
Man braucht, dass man zwingend einen Apple-Account und Xcode braucht, um überhaupt irgendwelche Apps zu machen.
Ich meine, warum brauche ich einen Mac, um iOS-Anwendungen zu kompilieren oder zu machen?
Okay, was trendet denn sonst noch so?
Wir gucken uns mal wieder an.
Trending heute.
Und trending...
This week.
Okay.
Ähm, auf dem ersten Platz trendet irgendwie Advanced Java in Chinesisch.
Das sind zwei Sachen, die mir nicht liegen.
Sowohl Chinesisch als auch Java.
Deswegen überspringe ich das mal.
Was ein edler Chat. Das ist bester Chat hier.
Tester Sunshine. 1, 2, 3.
Das kenne ich noch.
Leute, wisst ihr noch, was das war?
Ich habe es mir gemerkt.
Ich weiß noch, was das war.
1, 2, 3, 0, 6.
Wisst ihr es auch noch?
Das war die chinesische Bahn.
Genau.
Quai.
Chinesische Bahn-App.
Ähm.
Okay, was auch immer. Irgendein Buch.
Outline.
Fastest Wiki and Knowledge Base for Cryo-Teams.
Da zeige ich es mal her.
6,8 Sterne.
Hä?
Ist es jetzt Self-Hostel oder nicht?
Ah, man kann es selbst self-hosten.
Okay.
Wahrscheinlich
ist das für Leute, die auch wollen, dass ihre Dokumentation gelesen wird.
Okay.
Weil alle, die wollen, dass es nicht gelesen wird, schreiben es einfach in Confluence rein.
Und sobald es in Confluence drin ist, guckt nie wieder irgendeine Seele da rein.
Haha.
Ich kann, ich kann das schon abrechnen, wenn ich will.
Aber das ist komplett schon in Fleisch und Blut übergegangen.
Also diese chinesische Bahn hat auf jeden Fall beliebtere Apps als die deutsche Bahn.
So viel ist schon mal sicher.
Aber wahrscheinlich kommt die chinesische Bahn auch pünktlicher als die deutsche Bahn.
Sag mal, wie viel chinesische Riemen.
Die chinesische Repos-Trenden ist ja krass, ey.
Guck dir das mal an.
Alp Github ist voller chinesische Repos.
Die Trenden.
Spring plus Spring MVC klingt auch sehr nach Java.
Motrix.
Habe ich noch nie was von gehört.
Download Manager.
Ich weiß gar nicht, dass man sowas noch verwendet.
Ah, chinesisch.
Leute, das ist bestimmt Elektron.
Das ist safe eine Elektron-Anwendung.
Ich sag's euch.
Ja, Igitt.
Oben stand Elektron, habe ich nicht gesehen.
Mr. Opie.
Ja, so hätte ich das ja auch gerne.
Motrix.
So wie Matrix, nur mit O.
Irgendwelche Bücher.
Learn View Source Code.
Hä?
Auf jeden Fall auch wieder was in Chinesisch.
Aber Thumbs up, Leute.
Thumbs up.
Hier, Daumen hoch.
Ah, yes.
Excellent.
Exquisite Text.
Gibt's bei dir eigentlich auch Kontakt zum Friseur?
Klar.
Friseur kannte ich ja auch schon, bevor ich ganz YouTube-Zeug gemacht habe.
Dark Table.
Habe ich noch nie was von gehört.
Was ist das?
Fotogramme.
Oder?
Photography Workflow Application and Raw Developer.
Okay, wenn man die Projektbeschreibung liest, aber keinen blassen Schimmer hat, was es ist.
Ja, okay.
Ich mach keine Fotos.
So wie Lightroom.
Bloß Dark.
Awesome Design Tools.
Best Design Tools.
Boah.
Von Lisa Ziuba.
Das ist Lisa.
The best design tools and plugins for everything.
Okay, ist recht umfangreich.
Ich glaube, das kann man sich tatsächlich mal speichern.
Was immer da so alles drin ist.
Screenshot Tools.
Warum nicht?
Aber es scheint so klar.
Man nennt das Awesome schon im Trend.
Diese Awesome Lists.
Ist ja angesagt.
Wusstet ihr, dass es eine Awesome List of Awesome Lists gibt?
Das ist Next Level.
Unter Darkroom verstehen aber viele was anderes.
Ja, schon.
Allerdings die meisten Leute, die was mit Fotos machen, wahrscheinlich nicht.
Business Card Linux.
What?
Awesome Hacking Tools.
Developer Roadmap.
Die Developer Roadmap.
Roadmap to become a Web Developer in 2019.
Das wäre doch was für Surf Jelly vorhin gewesen.
Äh.
Frr.
Springboot.
Springboot plus View.
In China ist Java anscheinend voll angesagt.
Von den Trending Repos sind die Hälfte chinesisch und die Hälfte davon ist Java.
Hä?
Was habe ich da vor mir, Leute?
Ich habe eine Bildumgebung für Programme.
Vor mir, die ich auf einem F1C100 irgendwie laufen lassen kann und davon kann ich mir dann eine Visitenkarte bauen, oder was?
What?
Wenn du die Wahl zwischen Avira Free und Windows Defender hättest, was würdest du dazu nehmen und warum Windows Defender?
Einfach weil es dabei ist und mir nicht noch zusätzlichen Crap installiert.
Ich verstehe hier von dir nicht den Sinn, aber es ist nice.
Developer Roadmap.
Okay, ein paar Buzzwords.
Solid Kiss.
Ja.
Agni.
Okay.
Solid sagt mir was.
Kiss sagt mir was.
Was zur Hölle ist Jagni?
Jagni.
Du wirst es nicht brauchen.
Die Visitenkarte hat was.
Ja, finde ich auch.
Warum sind Virenprogramme unnötig?
Weil der Windows Defender eigentlich alles das macht, was andere Virenprogramme auch machen, ohne den ganzen anderen Crap dabei zu haben.
Was lernt man sonst noch?
Git.
Ja gut, damit verdiene ich mein Geld.
Das ist eigentlich Basic Terminal Usage.
Data Structures.
Algorithms.
Kriege ich alles gebacken.
Ich kriege Jagni sagt mir gar nichts, aber Solid und furchtbar.
Ich kann euch nicht aus dem Kopf sagen, für was die einzelnen Buchstaben in Solid stehen.
Single Responsibility.
Frag mich nicht.
Keine Ahnung.
Zu viel Theorie.
Ich programmier lieber als Theorie zu craften.
Semantic Versioning.
SSH.
HTTPS.
Design Patterns.
Character Encodings.
Ja, vor allem da muss man sich leiten.
Leider immer noch 2019 Gedanken machen.
Verfolgst du den Chaos Communication Kongress?
Nee, ich guck mir wieder die, ähm, die Casts, also die, die, die, die, die Worts an, wenn's fertig ist.
Was wir uns unbedingt angucken müssen, ist, ähm, Bahn Mining.
Es hängt irgendwie ein bisschen grad der Browser.
Das muss man uns angucken, wenn's raus ist.
Ich muss mal kurz den Browser neu starten, irgendwie hängt der, irgendwie spackt der mega rum.
Weiß nicht so genau warum.
Aber er spackt rum.
Na, jetzt geht's.
Ähm, wann ist denn der Vortrag über...
Wann ist denn der Vortrag?
Der müsste doch jetzt irgendwie sein.
Das ist doch jetzt irgendwann.
Da ist es doch, ja.
Bahn Mining.
Ist das der Nachfolger von Springer Mining... von Spiegel Mining, ja.
Das ist der Typ mit der Xerox Drucker Geschichte und Spiegel Mining, genau.
Das gucken wir uns an.
Alter, was spackt das denn jetzt hier gerade so rum?
Wisst ihr was?
Windows Style, wir rebooten einfach, wenn's nicht funktioniert.
Eats.
Einfach rebooten immer.
Ne, ein paar Tabs zu machen.
So.
Pum.
Also, an welchem, an welchem...
Das läuft doch jetzt gerade irgendwo, oder?
Ist das nicht gerade jetzt am Laufen?
Ach ne, 28.12.
Also über, übermorgen.
Das gucken wir uns...
Also, das Wort davon gucken wir uns dann auf jeden Fall an.
Zorin schon durch, ja.
Seit 20 Minuten oder so.
Wir gucken uns jetzt noch kurz die aktuellen Github Trends an, während ich am Fuddern bin.
Noch mehr chinesische Repos.
Was macht das?
Ah.
Der guckt, ob das Ding wie anfällig ist gegen irgendwelche bekannten Sicherheitslücken oder so.
Sieht doch ganz cool aus.
Oder brauchbar, je nachdem.
Für was?
Was läuft da gerade?
Gradius Gaiden.
Snowfield.
Irgend so ein Baller-Ding aus...
Sieht aus wie aus Super Nintendo-Zeiten.
Wie nicht die Musik, was dann?
Hä?
Ach so, das Repo.
Das ist hier...
X-Ray.
Keine Ahnung.
Irgend, irgendein chinesisches, äh, ähm, Hacking oder Security-Tool.
Das aktuelle Thema.
Wie heißt das?
X-Ray.
And so.
Ist einfach.
Hallo!
Wir gucken uns die aktuellen GitHub-Trends an.
Und nebenbei futter ich was.
witnesses.
Das ist, wenn man keinen Bock auf Arduino und C++ hat, dann macht man es hier mit dem
offiziellen ESP-Framework.
Homemade Machine Learning.
Incubator Hoodie.
Federsack.
Hört sich an wie ein Staubsauger oder?
Mein Federsack.
Gut, war jetzt nicht so viel Spannendes dabei.
Unglaublich viele chinesische Repos.
Ok.
was ist was ist die woche getrennt china bahn china also die china bahn brauche
echt viele apps oh gott jetzt geht's los leute jetzt ist
vorbei jetzt können wir noch nicht mal mehr den source code lesen aus china
jetzt wird der source code auch noch in chinesisch geschrieben
wenn jan lang hat das ist irgend so eine esoterische programmiersprache so was
wie brainfuck nur für nur für oder lolcode was wir letztens hatten nur für
chinesisch das ist next level leute da ist da hat
er hat jetzt auf springbu demo also eins muss man echt sagen chinesische repos
sind ganz stark im kommen und die chinesen verwenden unglaublich gerne
java wie es aussieht
und die chinesen verwenden unglaublich gerne java wie es aussieht
ich verstehe es zwar nicht aber java ist da voll angesagt ja white space habe ich
schon mal was zugelesen chinesische dichter sind auch auf github
eingetroffen machine learning from scratch na gut also python repo natürlich richtig
mia ota auch java ganze china repos sind in java habt ihr eine ahnung dass die qr reader oder so
habt ihr eine ahnung warum die chinesischen repos alle in java sind
ja
java oder die chinesische bahn die es in peisen sie schafft weniger warum mögen
die oracle mehr als microsoft das muss jetzt mal einer erklären microsoft ist
böse ja viel besser oder wie 14
das ist eine china java script kongress lied code animation zum teufel ist lied
code ist das ist das chinesische stack overflow das ist das chinesische stack
overflow das ist das chinesische udemy oder sowas
nee doch nicht das ist das dass das ist das chinesische stack overflow oder so
was in der richtung die seite ist gut schnell
es ist weder noch nee es ist eine übungs plattform eine chinesische
irgendwie oder ist noch nicht mal chinesisch ist ist das ist so coding
challenge geschichten okay da könnten wir auch ein paar sachen machen
challenger doom emacs ich habe schon gedacht die spielen doom in emacs aber es
ist einfach nur es ist einfach nur eine emacs konflikt die doom heißt ich habe
schon gedacht sie haben es geschafft in emacs
doom zu spielen es würde mich nicht wundern wenn man den
emacs doom spielen kann ehrlich gesagt also elisp ist wirklich eine sache die
muss man hassen ein mystik good job
wechat externe ok das ist china china crawlab ok das ist irgendwelche
durchsuchmaschinen seata was high performance open source distributed
transactions das hat man das letzte mal schon wussten nicht was es ist da ist
wieder da ist wenn die matrix mit oh das hatten wir auch schon go micro micro
services development framework was braucht man dafür den extra framework
für was macht es irgendwie viel viel magic im hintergrund der der der aspekt
bei microservices liegt eigentlich auf micro wo man eigentlich davon ausgehen
müsste die sind so schön runtergebrochene isoliert die service dass
man hat keine special frameworks verbraucht aber anscheinend habe ich
mich getäuscht ich weiß nicht nämlich ich checke auch nicht was es macht ach
das ist jetzt verstehe ich das ist ein framework dass die ganz das einfache ist
dass dann die unterschiedlichen micro services miteinander ordentlich
kommunizieren können ich denke mir manchmal so so weil erst der aktuelle
trend ist aber ich denke mir mal so wenn man dann 50 microservices gebaut hat und
daraus wieder quasi eine anwendung stricken muss wie die zusammenarbeiten
vielleicht hätte man gleich eine komplette anwendung machen sollen
anstatt 50 microservices die zusammengehören
weiß nicht wie ich dazu old school für stb ja so sieht es aus bei uns auf der
arbeit auch krass wo sie jetzt angefangen haben
so haben jetzt erzählt sie nach dem oder alles in die cloud alles in die
cloud und was macht man jetzt die server die halt total einfach umzuziehen sind
packt man in die cloud aber nicht etwa indem man die anwendung so entwickelt
dass sie gut in es laufen könnte man macht einfach eine vm in es und sagt
dann wir sind in der cloud als würdest den unterschied machen ob man die vm
auf dem alten esx cluster laufen lässt oder in der cloud ja gut so ist das aber
halt wenn
ja gut so ist das aber halt wenn
nicht gut so ist das aber nicht mit den vm einfach嘛
işte wenn man sie wirklich eh alle ein водensystemOM.de
ist mal проц Grund dass ich das mit den vm verwendet bin
es nicht was da habt ihr gerne
ich muss doch ich ehrlich sagen eigentlich bemüht auch zwei flällen
ja was die weh theoretisch ist das ist das so dass sie natürlich recht
Wir haben nicht mal Kubernetes. Es ist auch gar nicht mal so schlecht, wenn man nicht jeden Scheiß mitmachen muss.
Bei uns macht Kubernetes mehr Probleme, als so die klassische Virtualisierungsinfrastruktur gemacht hat.
Mehr Probleme und vor allem anders gelagerte Probleme, wo man auch nicht direkt weiß, was Sache ist.
Weil Kubernetes ist schon etwas kryptisch an manchen Stellen.
Libra.
Ist das eine Kryptowährung in Rust?
Das hat ja auch in Rust gefehlt, eine Kryptowährung.
Aber ne, ist das nicht dieses Facebook-Ding?
Ist das nicht dieses Facebook-Ding? Oder verwechsel ich das jetzt?
Ne, das ist was anderes, oder?
Warum taucht da Facebook nicht auf?
Denken Sie, das ist keine gute Werbung, wenn da Facebook auftaucht?
Facebook taucht hier überhaupt nicht auf drinnen.
Proxy-Pool auf Chinesisch, alles klar.
Ah, jetzt, jetzt, jetzt.
Das ist ein Lautpalenzer, oder?
Das erinnert mich ein bisschen an den Epic Sucks-Guy.
Alibaba Druid.
Wisst ihr, wenn man selbst nicht nach China geht, wenn einem das zu weit ist, dann lässt man einfach China zu sich kommen mit AliExpress.
Die Musik ist ein bisschen laut jetzt.
Was machst du? Wir gucken uns GitHub-Trends an.
Alibaba Druid. Was ist das?
Was ist das?
Wieso so viel China-Kram? Weil GitHub gerade mit Rennigen-Repos voll ist mit China-Kram.
Druid is one of the best database connection pools written in Java.
Sorry, Java.
Written in Java.
Druid provides powerful monitoring for...
Äh...
Gnoleryx.
Sagt dir GitHub was?
GitHub ist ne...
...Webseite, wo Leute ihren Source-Code drauf hosten.
Und die Trending-Repos sind die, die aktuell besonders viele Sterne kriegen.
Also die besonders beliebten...
Ähm...
Die besonders beliebten Gruppen, quasi.
An Projekten.
Wenn man sich GitHub-Trends anguckt, dann weiß man, was aktuell angesagt ist.
Und was wir festgestellt haben, ist, dass sau viele chinesischen Repos angesagt sind.
Ist Java nicht veraltet in China?
Nein.
Nein, ist es nicht.
Und in China erst recht nicht.
Da ist ja alles...
Okay, Leute, ich hab keine Ahnung, was es ist.
Es ist...
Es ist ein...
Ein...
Es ist die...
Der beste Database-Connection-Pool.
Ich dachte, ein Connection-Pool ist nicht was Ausgelagertes, sondern...
Äh...
Entweder was im Application-Server oder was auf Datenbankseite.
Geh mal auf die Benchmarks.
Wo sind denn die?
Bench...
Ah, hier.
Benchmarks.
Tomcat-JDPC.
Das ist so das Standard-Ding.
Leute, wie wär's mit Einheiten dahinter schreiben?
Was...
Was für...
Was bedeutet die Zahl überhaupt?
Radwürfel.
Connections?
Sind das Connections?
Ey, ich...
Keine Ahnung.
Ich versuche es auch gar nicht zu verstehen.
Anzahl der Threads?
Ne, Anzahl der Threads sind es hier oben.
Ich glaub, das sind...
Connections pro Thread oder...
Irgendwie sowas.
Ne, weniger ist besser.
Also, man braucht weniger Connections, um das Gleiche zu machen.
Irgendwie so.
Leute, kein Schimmer.
Millisekunden.
Das wär verdammt lang.
311 Millisekunden für eine Datenbankantwort.
Geschweige denn 32 Sekunden, Alter.
32 Sekunden.
Kannst du erstmal Kaffee machen, bevor die Webseite aufgeht.
Kannst du erstmal den hier machen, bevor die Webseite geladen ist.
Mit 32 Sekunden.
Und zur Datenbank.
Oh, das ist gut hier.
Das ist gut.
Das ist ein GUI.
Äh, ein Vektor.
Vektor mal...
Mal, äh...
Library für...
Für C++.
Da kann man...
Kann man Spiele...
Gaming Interfaces und so mitmachen.
Für normale Anwendungen jetzt verwendet man es eher nicht, aber...
Das ist nice.
Also, Striker, ich glaub, das ist was anderes.
Aber sicher bin ich mir da auch nicht.
Einige Cheat-Provider nutzen das.
Ja, bietet sich an.
Das ist halt quasi so eine...
So eine In...
In-Process...
In...
Wie nennt man das?
Ähm...
Immediate Mode, genau.
Also musst du quasi jedes Mal alles neu malen.
Das ist halt schön klein und man kann halt schön...
Schön damit einfach ein bisschen GUI malen.
Das wundert mich nicht, dass das einige Cheat-Anbieter benutzen.
Verwenden aber auch genauso viel Legit-Anwendung, um damit irgendwelche Overlays zu malen.
Guck mal, sogar Microsoft hat ein extra Repo für Chinese Students.
AI Education.
Magnet W App.
Ist das sowas wie Monk HW?
Magnet W?
Monk HW?
Ist das ein Kalender?
Ich checke nämlich nicht so genau, was es ist.
Ne Notizblock?
Ne Link...
Ein Link...
Ein Link-Manager?
Was könnte das sein, Leute?
Ein Download-Manager?
Ein Torrent-Client!
Das ist ein Torrent-Client!
Jetzt change ich das.
Die Torrents machen wir garantiert nicht auf.
Okay, also Leute.
Die Trending-Repos des Tages und der Woche waren jetzt ein bisschen enttäuschend.
Gucken wir, scrollen wir nochmal schnell drüber.
China-Repo, China-Repo, China-Repo... Halo!
Da war es doch China-Repo.
Mr. Chief.
Ah ja, eindeutig.
Da ist er.
Ähm...
Blatter?
Was ist denn das Beste? Das kann man nicht sehen.
Das muss man über externe Seiten machen.
Wir haben uns das letzte Mal meist bewertete...
Wie hieß das denn? GitHub Stars oder so?
Most Stars?
Wie hieß denn das? Wir haben uns das letzte Mal sowas gefunden.
Get Most Wanted?
Nee, das war das nicht.
Stars?
Get Star Ranking, genau.
Ah, das war das.
So, und kann man das jetzt aufs Jahr über?
Nee, das ist nur insgesamt.
Man kann das nicht aufs Jahr über einstellen.
Es gibt meines Wissens nach nichts, wo man gucken kann, was ist das beliebteste Repo des Jahres.
Nee, das ist mir zu risikoreich.
Was haben wir uns das letzte Mal schon angeguckt?
GitHub Most Stars 2019.
Wir bräuchten sowas wie Social Blade für GitHub.
Popular JavaScript Repos.
Git hör auf.
Leider kann man das nicht nach Ja sortieren.
View for React.
Die haben es verdient.
Die haben es wirklich verdient.
Octoverse GitHub.
Das ist doch dieser Jahresbericht, oder?
Aber den gibt es doch für dieses Jahr noch gar nicht.
Oder ist das schon der aktuelle?
Aber da haben die keine Repos drin.
Das haben wir uns doch schon mal angeguckt.
Da hatten sie doch keine Repos drin.
Top and Trending Projects.
Top Open Source Projects.
Die Musik.
Was ist das?
Wie ist Code?
Das wundert mich nicht.
Wo sind denn die Sachen nur für dieses Jahr?
SP.NET Core.
Das geht ab.
Aber gut, die haben das auch unbenannt.
Die haben das auch neu aufgemacht.
Was ist Helm Schatz?
Cyplus ist Frontend-Test in JavaScript.
Cypus ist Frontend-Test in JavaScript.
Zugewin chart telefon.
Zhang yao brillantes über GPS.
Zhang yao brillantes über IP地図目的科技、
Zhang yao brillantes über X καo Çünkü。
Zhang yao brillantes über IQ。
economically connected in China.
mal cross-plattform oh oh das müssen wir uns mal angucken cross-plattform gui ist ja so meine meine
geheime ein geheimes hobby cross-plattform gui muss mir alles angucken was cross-plattform gui
ist es sieht ein bisschen nach javascript aus oder 6 monate dankeschön huge big brain haben
wir mal nennen aber ein beispiel aber mal ein example extra example hello world wir brauchen
der pokédex wir brauchen wir brauchen ein hello world example rast kann schon hässlich sein ja
also rast ist definitiv keine sprache die man einfach lesen kann und das ist doch schönes rast
ich meine gut es ist es ist nicht nichts verglichen mit c++ sie
plus plus ist das ist der teufel in person was das angeht ach hier macht man hier macht
man das ui view row new spacing allein items ok also leute wir müssen uns mal abklopfen die
wichtigsten sachen die man bei einem gui framework braucht beziehungsweise man gucken kann ob es was
taugt gibt es ein webview und gibt es die möglichkeit gpu beschleunigten content einzubinden gibt es ein webview
browser moment das ganze ding ist so fall ja ja ich mache das öfters ok also ein webview gibt es
anscheinend schon mal nett gibt es die möglichkeit x irgendwie einzubinden oder oder anscheinend das muss
ja mal angucken
das macht einen echt interessanten eindruck weil es fehlen wirklich ordentliche cross
plattform gui libraries das fehlen es gibt kaum was du hast aktuell so die auswahl zwischen pest
und cholera du kannst cute mit c++ machen oder noch ein python interpreter mit bundlen oder du machst
elektron das war's deswegen hoffe ich ja auch auf flutter dass sie da was ordentliches abliefern mobile sieht schon wieder besser aus
ok man Nicki möchte markdown html content rändern wie würde ich das machen html kann man html drin rendern
und weiß es nicht wobei die docs ja auch ein bisschen die docs ein bisschen sehr gewöhnungsbedürftig sind ja freuen sich alle freuen sich alle drauf dass ich so viel 1 tippe in der ur sound
profil 1 tippe in der ur sound
prokratische art vorstellt hat man sich alle drauf dass ich so viele 1 tippe in der ur sound
Browser Bar, gerade wieder.
A Web Run Time.
Ne, das ist Web Assembly.
Oder was anderes.
Build in Render Supporting
Work in Metal DX11DX.
Okay.
Vielleicht sollte man das mal ausprobieren.
Also ich finde nicht, dass da drin
steht, ob es ein WebView gibt.
Build in Widgets.
Cross-Platform
Support.
Aber ob es ein Build in WebView
gibt, sehe ich
da jetzt nicht.
Kaminsky
96, ja.
Jetzt wirst du es nie wieder nicht mehr sehen können.